WE'RE GOING TO HAVE OUR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
GOVERNOR'S -- MAY BE REVISED
PROPOSALS.
I KNOW ACTION TODAY JUST HEARING
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS.
IN THIS OF COURSE IS FOCUSED ON
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THE
QUICK K. TWELVE PORTION OF THAT
SO LET'S BEGIN AND BRING UP FROM
THE FINANCE A LEO.
ADD. TO HEAR THE GOVERNOR'S.
MAY REVISED PROPOSALS
.
OKAY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PLEASE AND GET.
MORNING MR SHARE MEMBERS ERIN AT
AREA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHEN
PROVIDE YOU TODAY.
WITH JUST A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE CALCULATION OF THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT MINIMUM.
GUARANTEE AT THE MAYOR VISION
ALSO SOME OF THE MAJOR EARLY
EDUCATION AND KATO SPENDING
PROPOSALS WITHIN I BELIEVE
COMMUNTY COLLEGES WILL BE
COVERED IN A SEPARATE HEARING
THIS WEEK.
AS FAR AS A CALCULATION OF THE
GUARANTEES CONCERN THE MAYOR
VISION PROPOSES THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF FUNDING EVER UNDER THE
PROP NINETY MINIMUM GUARANTEE.
AT EIGHTY ONE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS UP FROM EIGHTY POINT
SEVEN BILLION AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
AND UP FROM SEVENTY EIGHT POINT
ONE BILLION IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND UP
ALL THE WAY FROM FORTY SEVEN
BILLION DURING THE TROUGH OF THE
RECESSION.
WE CONTINUE REVENUE GROWTH
DURING THIS ECONOMIC RECOVERY
FROM THE GREAT RECESSION.
TOTAL GENERAL FUND REVENUES AT
THE MAY REVISION ARE ESTIMATED
TO BE A HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AN INCREASE OF
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS OVER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN LEVELS.
AT A TOTAL OF EIGHTY ONE POINT
ONE BILLION THAT'S A PER PUPIL
EXPENDITURE FROM PROP NINETY
EIGHT OF ABOUT ELEVEN THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
DOLLARS AN INCREASE OF ALMOST
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS PER PEOPLE
OVER THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FISCAL YEAR LEVELS.
COMPARED TO GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
FUNDING UNDER THE GUARANTEE IS
UP ALMOST SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OVER THE
THREE YEAR.
BUDGET WINDOW PERIOD.
WITH A FACTOR CHANGES AT THE MAY
REVISION MOST NOTABLY A DECREASE
IN PER CAPITA PERSONAL INCOME
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
MINIMUM GUARANTEE WILL ALSO
INCLUDE WITHIN IT A DEPOSIT.
INTO THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT OR PROP
NINETY EIGHT READING THE RESERVE.
OF THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS AS REQUIRED FOR
THE LANGUAGE AND PROPOSITION.
TWO SIMILAR TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET -- K. FOURTEEN EDUCATION
UNDER THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE WILL
NOT EXPERIENCE A REDUCTION IN
PRIOR CURRENT YEAR -- FUNDED
APPROPRIATION LEVELS DESPITE
DECLINES IN THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE COMPARED TO THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT -- BECAUSE
WE ARE CONTINUING TO MAINTAIN
OVER A PREPARATION IN THE PRIOR
YEAR -- PREVIOUSLY -- FORTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS NOW THE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
AND SECONDLY WE ARE CONTINUING
TO USE -- SETTLE UP PAYMENT IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO FUND
SOME OF THE ON GOING OBLIGATION
OFFER LCF IN IN -- TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BRIEFLY I'LL
COVER JUST SOME OF OUR MAJOR
SPENDING PROPOSALS -- WE'RE
CONTINUING TO PRIORITIZE FUNDING
UNDER THE LC A PFAFF -- AS WE
CONTINUE -- TO TO IMPLEMENT THE
FORMULA NOW THAT IT'S FULLY
IMPLEMENTED -- WITH THE DECREASE
IN COLA FROM THREE POINT FOUR
SIX DOWN TO NOW THREE POINT TWO
SIX AT THE MAY REVISION -- TOTAL
FUNDING ON THE FORMULA IS STILL
ABOUT SIXTY THREE BILLION
DOLLARS -- BUT A SLIGHT
REDUCTION ON THE INCREMENTAL
INCREASE EVERY YEAR FROM TWO
BILLION TO JUST OVER ONE POINT
NINE BILLION NOW WITH THAT LOWER
COLON.
AND SPECIAL EDUCATION THE MAYOR
VISION BUILDS UPON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION BY INCREASING
FUNDING FOR THAT PROPOSAL BY
OVER A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AND NOW AT THE MERE VISION ONLY
USING.
EXCUSE ME ONLY USING ONGOING%
FUNDS INSTEAD OF A MIX OF ON
GOING AT ONE TIME BRINGING THE
TOTAL TO SIX HUNDRED NINETY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL FUND.
THIS FUNDING WILL BE USED TO
SUPPORT -- EXPANDED ITS SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES SCHOOL READY
TO SUPPORT LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES WITH HIGH PERCENTAGES
OF ALL STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND TO UNDEFEATED
PUPILS AS DISCUSSED PREVIOUSLY.
SO INCLUDING THE LC AFFECT THE
DECREASE FOR COULD KATO PROGRAMS
ATTRIBUTABLE TO CALL AT THE ME
REVISION IT'S JUST ABOUT SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS -- IN EARLY
EDUCATION THE MAYOR VISION
PROPOSES ADJUSTING THE START
DATE FOR NEW STATE PRESCHOOL
SLOTS.
PROVIDING TWELVE MONTH
ELIGIBILITY TO CAL WORK STAGE
ONE CHILD CARE PROGRAM PROVIDING
TWELVE POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDS FOR
EMERGENCY CHILDCARE DIVERSION
PILOT PROGRAM.
AND SOME MAJOR K. TWELVE BUT NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
SPENDING PROPOSALS I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT AS WELL IS THAT --
YOUR MAY REMEMBER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUT PROPOSAL FOR THREE BILLION
DOLLARS -- TO GOING TOWARDS THE
EMPLOYER SHARE OF THE CAL STIRS
UNFUNDED LIABILITY -- RATE
REDUCTION IN BOTH NINETEEN
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
GOVERNOR AND THE MAYOR VISION --
PROPOSES TO ADD AN ADDITIONAL
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TOWARDS PAYING DOWN THE
EMPLOYER SHARE RATE AND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY WHICH WILL
EFFECTIVELY TAKE THE RATE A
PROPOSED THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DEBATE REDUCTION FROM 1%. TO ONE
POINT 4% LOWERING THE RATE THAT
EMPLOYERS CAN EXPECT TO PAY FROM
EIGHTEEN POINT 1% IN NINETEEN
TWENTY DOWN TO SIXTEEN POINT 7% --
THE MAYOR VISION ALSO PROMOTE
PROPOSES TO REDUCE FUNDING
PROPOSED AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR KINDERGARTEN
FACILITIES. TO DOWN TO SIX
HUNDRED MILLION SO REDUCTION OF
A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION SUCH AS
IN A WAY THAT WE CAN -- BETTER
TARGET -- FUNDING UNDER THE
PROGRAM TO THOSE WHO -- WE FEEL
OF MOST APPROPRIATELY NEED IT AS
WE WORK TOWARDS EXPANDING FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN -- LESLIE IN
TEACHER RESOURCE.
TEACHER WORKFORCE EXCUSE ME THE
MAYOR VISION INCLUDES A HUNDRED
AND FORTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
TOTAL AS A MIX OF THE NONPROFIT
IS IN.
NINETY EIGHT OUR GENERAL FUND
AND ALSO SOME FEDERAL FUNDS ARE
GOING TOWARD PROMOTING NEW
TEACHERS AT SCHOOLS WITH A HIGH
NUMBER OF TEACHERS SERVING ON
EMERGENCY PERMITS -- PROVIDING
STATE WHY PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR TEACHERS ON
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING
INCLUSIVE PRACTICES AND SUBJECT
MATTER COMPETENCE IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE.
AND PROVIDE STATEWIDE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS AND OTHER
SCHOOL LEADERS.
WITHOUT OUR CONCLUDE MY COMMENTS
BUT HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
OUR COLONY COLLEAGUES AS
NECESSARY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAN A
COUPON WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I'LL BE
SPEAKING FROM A HANDOUT THAT THE
SERGEANT JUST DISTRIBUTED.
I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION GIVE
YOU A GOOD OVERVIEW OF THIS MAY
REVISION.
THE WAY WE THINK ABOUT IT THERE
ARE REALLY. THREE NUMBERS TO
FOCUS ON THAT KIND OF TELL THE
TALE OF WHAT'S IN THIS YEAR IS A
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE.
ARE THE FIRST TO SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FORTY SIX MILLION THAT'S THE
INCREASE IN PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT ACROSS THE ENTIRE BUDGET
PERIOD SO.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TO NINETEEN
TWENTY I THAT INCREASES MAINLY A
FUNCTION OF THE ADDITIONAL
GENERAL FUND REVENUE.
I THINK MOST OF YOU ARE AWARE WE
HAD A GOOD REVENUE MONTH IN
APRIL AND REVENUE ESTIMATES ARE
UP I'M A BIT Và COMPARED TO
WHERE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WAS
IN JANUARY -- TURNING-- TO PAGE
TWO OF OUR HAND OUT.
I THINK THE NEXT IMPORTANT
NUMBER IS THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
NINE MILLION THAT'S THE AMOUNT
OF THE STATE'S FIRST DEPOSIT
INTO THE STATE SCHOOL RESERVE.
A LOT OF FORMULAS.
KIND OF UNDER PEN THAT RESERVE
ACCOUNT BUT THE IDEA IS -- TO
THE FORMALIST TRY TO RECOGNIZE
HERE IS WHEN THE GUARANTEE IS
GOING OUT OF AN ABOVE AVERAGE
PACE AND SET ASIDE SOME OF THAT
FUNDING FOR TIGHTER FISCAL TIMES.
A DEPOSIT THE REQUIRED
SPECIFICALLY WHEN THE STATE
RECEIVES CAPITAL GAINS ABOVE
HAVE ITS LONG TERM AVERAGE.
AND WHEN THE MINIMUM GUARANTEED
IS ABOVE THE PRIOR YEAR FUNDING
LEVEL ADJUSTED FOR CHANGES IN
STUDENT ATTENDANCE AND INFLATION
FACTOR.
AND THEN THE FINAL NUMBER THAT
WE THINK IS IMPORTANT IS A
HUNDRED IN NINETEEN MILLION
THAT'S THE AMOUNT OF THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. FOR THE
GOVERNOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
PROPOSAL IN JANUARY THAT
PROPOSAL WAS A COMBINATION OF
ONE TIME AND I'M GOING SOURCES --
A REVISION UPS THAT. TO NEARLY
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION AND MAKES
ALL THE FUNDING I'M GOING --
BEYOND THE SCHOOL RESERVE
DEPOSIT AND TO THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION.
REALLY ALL OF THE REST OF THE
NEW FUNDING IN THIS PACKAGE IS
ASSOCIATED WITH TECHNICAL
CHANGES SO COVERING SLIGHTLY
HIGHER COSTS OF STUDENT
ATTENDANCE.
A FEW ITEMS NEW CUSTOMERS SINCE
JANUARY.
BEYOND THAT THERE'S REALLY NOT A
WHOLE LOT OF NEW FUNDING INSIDE
OF THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
PART OF THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
I TURNING TO PAGE THREE THIS IS
REALLY JUST MORE OF A TECHNICAL.
SUMMARY OF ALL OF THE SPECIFIC
SPENDING CHANGES TO GET INTO ALL
OF THOSE IN A SUBSEQUENT HEARING
SOMEWHAT SPEND ANY TIME ON ON
THOSE THAT TABLE NOW.
I TURNING TO PAGE.
FOUR WE THINK THIS PROVISION
THIS BEING THE VISION HAS
SEVERAL POSITIVE ELEMENTS. ONE
OF THE FIRST QUESTIONS -- I
ALWAYS WE LOOK AT IS BY THE
ESTIMATES OF THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE REASONABLE BECAUSE
THAT SET THE TABLE FOR ALL OF
THE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT WHAT THE
STATE -- MARK CAN AND WANTS TO
PROVIDE FOR SCHOOLS IN THE
COMING YEAR.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATES
OF GENERAL FUND REVENUE I
SLIGHTLY BELOW OURS WE THINK
THAT'S LARGELY BECAUSE WE HAD
I'M A LITTLE BIT -- MORE RECENT
DATA WHEN WE PREPARED OUR
ESTIMATES WE ALSO HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF A DIFFERENT WAY OF
MODELING THE EFFECTS OF INITIAL
PUBLIC OFFERINGS OF COMPANIES
THAT ARE BASED IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S BEEN KIND OF A BIG TOPIC
THE LAST FEW WEEKS AND MONTHS --
SO ACROSS THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
TO NINETEEN TWENTY PERIOD I
REVENUE ESTIMATES A LITTLE BIT
HIGHER -- BUT OUR ESTIMATES OF
THE GUARANTEE I REALLY ONLY A
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
ABOVE THE ADMINISTRATION OVER
THAT ENTIRE THREE YEAR PERIOD
THAT'S ONE OF THE CLOSEST.
THE CLOSEST I THINK WE'VE BEEN.
IN MANY YEARS AS FAR AS OUR
ESTIMATES OF THE GUARANTEE SO WE
THINK THAT BUT THE MAYOR VISION
IS A REASONABLE STARTING POINT
FOR YOUR BUDGET DELIBERATIONS --
THE DEPOSIT INTO THE STATE
SCHOOL RESERVE IS A SIGNIFICANT
DEVELOPMENT LOTS OF COMPLEX
CALCULATIONS -- UNDERMINE THAT
WE'VE REVIEWED -- BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATES THAT
DEPOSIT YOU THINK THEY'D WITH WE
THINK THEY ADMINISTER THE
FORMULAS ACCURATELY AND
CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT TO
PROPOSITION.
TWO AND IT'S WE THINK IT'S
SIGNIFICANT THAT FOR THE FIRST
TIME STATE REALLY HAS A
DEDICATED SOURCE OF FUNDING --
SET ASIDE NOW SPECIFICALLY TO
SUPPLEMENT THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEED DURING TIED TO IT
ECONOMIC TIMES YES I THINK THAT
COMPLEMENT SOME OF THE THINGS
YOU'VE DONE ELSEWHERE IN YOUR
BUDGET TO TRY. TO MOVE THE STATE
AND EVEN FOR MY FISCAL FOOTING --
THE MAYOR VISION ALSO REVISITS
THE MIX OF ONE TIME AND I'M
GOING PRO PROPOSALS AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THAT MIX
REALLY DETERMINES WHETHER YOU
HAVE.
REALLY A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT OR
SURPLUS GOING INTO.
YOUR BUDGET DELIBERATIONS IN
SUBSEQUENT YEARS.
AND IN THIS AREA WE THINK THE
MAYOR VISION IS A REALLY MOVING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAD
PROPOSED SPENDING ABOUT EIGHTY
MILLION MORE ON ON GOING
PROGRAMS THAN IT HAD AVAILABLE
ON GOING WE SOURCES SO A LITTLE
BIT OF A DEFICIT.
OVER THE LONG RUN OTHER NAY
REVISION ELIMINATES THAT AND IN
FACT IT SPENDS IT BUILDS IN A
SMALL SURPLUS OF ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION.
I HEADING INTO.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
THEN FINALLY ON THE PROGRAMMATIC
SIDE WE THINK THE CHANGES TO THE
KINDERGARTEN FACILITY GRANT
PROGRAM ARE ANOTHER POSITIVE
STEP.
OUT OUR ANALYSIS AND FOUND THAT
IT UNDER THE CURRENT PROGRAM A
LOT OF THOSE FUNDS ARE GOING TO
DISTRICTS THAT ALREADY RUN FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS.
AT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL I
THINK WOULD TRY TO GET THE
PROGRAM MORE TOWARD YOUR CORE
INTEREST WHICH WAS INCURRING
TRAJAN DISTRICTS TO CONVERT FROM.
A PARTY TO FULL DAY PROGRAMS.
WE THINK THAT THE MAN FOR THE
PROGRAM IS STILL LIKELY TO BE
LESS THAN SIX HUNDRED MILLION SO
IF YOU ARE LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
FREE UP FUNDING FOR YOUR OTHER
PRIORITIES YOU COULD CONSIDER
FUNDING A SMALLER AMOUNT. FOR
THAT GRANT PROGRAM.
I FINALLY TURNING TO PAGE FIVE A
HIGHLIGHT I JUST TOOK CONCERNS
WE THINK YOU SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT.
A ONE IS THAT EVEN THOUGH THE
MAYOR VISION DOES HAVE THIS
SMALL ONE TIME CUSHION OF ABOUT
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION.
THAT'S STILL VERY MODEST IN THE
CONTEXT OF WHAT YOU'VE DONE
PREVIOUSLY AND WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN
IN A RECESSION.
OVER THE PAST SIX YEARS YOU'VE
SET ASIDE AN AVERAGE OF ABOUT
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION A YEAR FOR
ONGOING.
ACTIVITIES SO -- AN APPRECIABLE
QUESTION IF THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEED DROPS.
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION IT
IS SOMETHING THAT COULD VANISH
VERY QUICKLY IF THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE SLOW AS WE HAVE AN
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
AND SO WE THINK AS YOU REVIEW
SOME OF THE SPECIFICS BUT
SPENDING PROPOSALS.
WHEN I THINK ABOUT -- SHIFTING A
LITTLE BIT MORE TOWARDS A ONE
TIME ACTIVITIES AND NOT QUITE AS
MUCH ON GOING SPENDING AS THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES.
IN TERMS OF SPEND SPECIFIC
SPENDING PROPOSALS -- WE DO IT
CAN I CONTINUE TO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION GRANT PROPOSAL -- ON
THIS -- ONE THE CONCERN IS THAT
THE FUNDING IS ALLOCATED
ACCORDING TO THE NUMBER ONE OF
THE FACTORS IN THE PROGRAM IS
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS WHO RIDE
IDENTIFIED WITH A DISABILITY.
AND OUR CONCERN IS THAT CREATES
A POOR INCENTIVES BECAUSE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE SUCCESSFUL IN
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES.
WITH EITHER FUNDING DROP UNDER
THIS PROGRAM AND DISTRICTS THAT
SORT OF MAINTAIN IDENTIFICATION
RATES -- THEY ACTUALLY CONTINUE
TO SEE IF THE SAME OR EVEN MORE
FUNDING.
AND IT'S NOT JUST POCKET CHANGE --
THE AMOUNT FOR DISTRICTS THAT
QUALIFY FOR THIS PROGRAM KIND OF
ON THE MARGIN EACH ADDITIONAL
STUDENT THE IDENTIFIER DON'T
IDENTIFY IS WORTH MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER STUDENT SO
IT'S A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT --
FISCAL COMMON SENATE FOR SOME OF
THESE DISTRICTS -- WHAT WE'VE WE
THINK YOU'VE GOT SOME OTHER
OPTIONS THAT MIGHT HAVE BETTER
ADDRESSED SOME OF YOUR LONG
STANDING CONCERNS WITH SPECIAL
EDUCATION -- ONE WOULD BE TO
FOCUS ON FINDING IT EQUALIZATION
WE THINK THAT WOULD DISTRIBUTE
FUNDING BOTH MORE BROADLY AND IT
WOULD ALSO REDUCE THE STRUGGLE
FUNDING INEQUITIES WITHOUT
CREATING ANY OF THESE.
KINDS OF INCENTIVE CONCERNS.
WE ALSO THINK YOU COULD CONSIDER
A PROVIDING SOME FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY FOR PRESCHOOL
SPECIAL EDUCATION CURRENTLY THAT
SOMETHING THAT DISTRICTS ARE
REQUIRED TO DO BUT THERE IS NO
DEDICATED FUND SOURCE FOR THAT.
A SO WITH THAT YOU'LL BE HEARING --
CAM THINGS OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
JUST TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
HOW PRESCHOOL AND CHILDCARE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MORNING SIR CORTEZ LA -- I JUST
OF A FEW HIGH LEVEL COMMENTS ON
CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL FUNDING
THE MAY REVISION HAS A FUNDING
FOR CHILDCARE PRESCHOOL --
PROGRAMS UP BY SEVENTY NINE
MILLION COMPARED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THIS IS A
COMBINATION OF DECREASE IN
GENERAL FUND AN INCREASE IN
FEDERAL FUNDS.
THE BOOK OF THE DECREASE IN
GENERAL FUND IS DUE TO THE LATER
START DATE FOR THIS FOR THE
STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS -- WITH
REGARD TO THE STATE PRESCHOOL
SLOTS -- THE GOVERNOR ALSO
WITHDRAWS HIS PLAN TO SERVE ALL
LOW INCOME FOUR YEAR OLDS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO WITH NOT HAVING A PLAN TO
SERVE ALL LOW INCOME FOUR YEAR
OLDS AND ALSO REMOVING THE WORK
REQUIRED REQUIREMENTS -- WE ARE
EVEN MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
REMOVING THE WORK REQUIREMENT
SIMILAR WITH THEIR CONCERNS IN
JANUARY.
JUST NOT HAVING THAT PLAN IN
PLACE TO SERVE ALL LOW INCOME
FOUR YEAR OLDS AND DOING THAT
ACTION -- THE GOVERNOR CONTINUES
TO PER OF MADE SOME TRAILER BILL
CHANGES TO THAT WITH SOMEONE
TIME PROPOSALS FOR FACILITIES
WORK FORCE AND PLANNING
INITIATIVES. FOR THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE WITH REGARD TO THE
FACILITY GRANT OF FUNDING --
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THE
LANGUAGE MINIMIZE MINIMIZE
LEGISLATIVE INPUT AS A LOT OF
SOME OF THE BASIC IMPLEMENTATION
DETAILS ARE.
ON THE ADMINISTRATION WILL
DETERMINE BY MARCH FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ANOTHER KEY
COMPONENT OF THE EARLY EDUCATION
BUDGET IS THE GOVERNOR PLANS --
TO HAS SOME FEDERAL FUND
INCREASING PLANS TO MAKE A
RECENT FEDERAL FUNDING BUT BUT
FUND GRANT A FOR CHILD CARE
SPECIFICALLY TREAT THAT IS
ONGOING.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION PLANS TO
SPEND THESE FEDERAL FUNDS IN A
VERY BIG WAY.
SOME WITH SOME PROGRAMMATIC
CHANGES IN THE STAGE ONE PROGRAM
AND ALSO GO CREATING A NEW
VOUCHERS A VOUCHER PILOT PROGRAM.
AND WE WOULD JUST NOTICES ONE
PLAN THAT THE IN THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER BUT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS QUITE A BIT
DISCRETION ON HOW TO SPEND.
AND HOTTEST BUT THESE FUNDS AND
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS BUT
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
A GOOD MORNING -- MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AND STAFF MY NAME'S KIND
JACKSON ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
APPRECIATES THE GOVERNOR'S --
CONTINUE COMMITMENT TO K. --
TWELVE PARTICULARLY IN CERTAIN
AREAS OF THE BUDGET -- TO
INCLUDE THE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER TRAINING STEAM IN EARLY
EDUCATION.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT OUR STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LATEST
TECHNOLOGY AND CONTINUE TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL DIGITAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES.
SO THE SUPERINTENDENT IS
APPRECIATIVE TO SEE A MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE MAY REVISION FOR
STATE -- COMPUTER SCIENCE
COORDINATOR AS WELL AS FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO EXPAND
BROADBAND INTERNET CAPACITY TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN THE TEACHER
PIPELINE. NINETY MILLION DOLLARS
TO PROVIDE FOUR THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED TEACHERS UP TO TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN GRANTS FOR
TEACHING IN CERTAIN SCHOOLS AND
SUBJECT AREAS.
ALMOST FORTY MILLION ONE TIME
FUND TO PROVIDE TRAINING AND
RESOURCES THE CLASSROOM TEACHERS.
INCLUDING TEACHERS CARE
PROFESSIONALS IN ORDER TO BUILD
CAPACITY AROUND INCLUSIVE
PRACTICES SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING COMPUTER SCIENCE A
RESTORATIVE PRACTICES AS WELL AS
SUBJECT MATTER COMPETENCY. TO
INCLUDE STING.
ANOTHER THIRTEEN POINT NINE
MILLION ONGOING FEDERAL FUNDS
FOR PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR K. TWELVE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS ADMINISTRATORS TO
PROVIDE THE KNOWLEDGE SKILLS AND
COMPETENCIES.
NECESSARY TO SUCCESSFULLY
SUPPORT THE DIVERSE STUDENT
POPULATIONS THAT WE SERVE.
WERE ALSO -- SUPPORTIVE.
AND WE'RE GRATEFUL TO SEE THE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS IN K.
TWELVE OUTSIDE OF PROP.
NINETY EIGHT THE ADDITIONAL FOUR
POINT NOT A FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION BILLION DOLLARS OF NON
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDING IS
SIGNIFICANT.
THESE RESOURCES WILL HELP OUR
DISTRICTS AND SCHOOLS AND COUNTY
OFFICES PREPARE OUR STUDENTS. TO
SUCCEED IN THE FUTURE FOR
EXAMPLE THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARSIN ONE
TIME PROP NINETY EIGHT
INVESTMENTS ND CAL STIRS.
THIS IS SIGNIFICANT IN THAT IT
WILL PROVIDE THE IMMEDIATE
FISCAL RELIEF TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FOR THE RISING COSTS
OF PENSIONS.
AND AS WE KNOW THIS IS IMPORTANT
TO SCHOOLS SO THAT THEY CAN
MAINTAIN THEIR COMMITMENT TO US
RESPECTFUL RETIREMENT FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND TEACHERS WHILE
ALSO MEETING THEIR FINANCIAL
OPERATING OBLIGATIONS.
THE SUPERINTENDENT SUPPORTS AND
APPRECIATES THE AND ADDITIONAL
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN MILLION
DOLLARS -- PROPOSING TO MEET MAY
REVISE FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING ENSURING THAT OUR
ELEAZAR CAN MEET THE NEEDS OF
OUR STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
UNDER PROVISIONS OF THE ID A
RECOGNIZING THAT OUR STATE'S
HIGHEST NEED YOUTH OFTEN REQUIRE
SIGNIFICANT SUPPORT.
SERVICES EMPLACEMENTS
SIMULTANEOUSLY THE
SUPERINTENDENT IS CALLING ON THE
US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
CONGRESS TO MEET THEIR FALL I D.
E. A..
OBLIGATIONS.
ANOTHER VERY IMPORTANT ITEM IS
AFFORDABLE TEACHER HOUSING.
WE HAVE SEEN BODIES OF EVIDENCE
AND WE SEE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THE DIFFICULTIES THAT OUR
TEACHERS HAVE BEEN OBTAINING
AFFORDABLE AND SECURE HOUSING.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
INVESTING IN COMMUNITIES THAT
WILL ULTIMATELY SUPPORT
AFFORDABLE WORKFORCE HOUSING SO
THAT TEACHERS CAN LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY WORK.
IT IS VITAL THAT OUR DISTRICT
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY OFFICES
RECRUIT THE BEST AND BRIGHTEST
TEACHERS FOR STUDENTS.
WHEN WE INVEST IN OUR TEACHERS
THEY WILL INVEST IN OUR STUDENTS?
THE MAY REVISION INCLUDE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
TO PARTNER WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO INCREASE HOUSING
PRODUCTION THROUGH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND GENERAL PURPOSE
FUNDING.
OF WHICH JURISDICTIONS WOULD
RECEIVE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION OF THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION. TO SUPPORT
TECHNICAL ASSISTING AND STAFFING
DEVELOPMENT PLANS TO REACH OUR
STATE WHY GOALS.
WHAT THE MAY REVISE DOES IS ADD
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION SAYS GEORGE
THIS IS JURISDICTIONS ELIGIBLE
FOR PORTION OF THE TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS?
THE MAY REVISE ALSO PROPOSES TO
EXPAND STATE TAX CREDITS UP TO
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY UP
TO TWO HUNDRED OF THE NEWLY
AUTHORIZED CREDITS WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO INCREASE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF MIXED INCOME
HOUSING PROJECTS.
SERVING A BROADER RANGE OF
INCOMES UP TO A HUNDRED AND 20%
OF THE A. M. I. AND WOULD ALLOW
MORE TEACHERS ACCESS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
THE SUPERINTENDENT IS ALSO VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE MAY
REVISIONS PROPOSALS FOR EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE.
IN CLOSING WE'RE APPRECIATIVE OF
THE POSITIVE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE HAVE WITH
THE COMMITTEE THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS RECOGNIZED AND
SUPPORTED THE ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO IMPLEMENT THE NEW
AND EXISTING PROGRAMS AND HAVE
PROVIDED POSITIONS TO ENSURE
THAT THE PROGRAMS WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED PROPERLY.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADMINISTRATION TO IRON OUT ANY
DETAILS IN THE MAY REVISIONS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OF A FEW QUESTIONS BUT
START OFF WITH COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MR O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS -- PERSONAL WITH
REGARD TO PROP NINETY EIGHT THE
CALL IS BEING DECREASED.
FROM THREE POINT FOUR SIX TO
THREE POINT TWO SIX IS THAT
ACCURATE THAT'S CORRECT.
IN WHY I FIND THAT UNFORTUNATE I
THINK THAT BUYS IN TO THE IDEA.
THAT PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT IS
THE CEILING IS OPPOSE OF FLOOR
THERE'S NOTHING THAT SAYS.
WE CAN'T EVEN INCREASE IT MORE
THAN THE PROPOSED NOW PROPOSES
THREE POINT TWO SIX SO I JUST I
JUST THINK THAT THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE I THINK SHE WILL OF
OF THREE POINT -- TWO SIX OKAY
IF IT EATS INTO THE GENERAL FUND
THAT GOES BEYOND THE CEILING I'M
QUITE FINE WITHOUT I THINK
EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM SHOULD BE
FINE WITH THAT.
BUT AGAIN WILL AND ONE THING
ONLY COME FOR WHAT IS
CONSISTENTLY IN THIS HEARING
ROOM.
FOLKS COME IN AND THEY THEY THEY
CONSISTENTLY ACT.
AS THOUGH PROPOSITION NINETY IS
THE CEILING OPPOSED TO THE FLOOR
SO THAT THAT'S THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE -- SO IT'S I I WOULD
SAY THAT'S A LESSER COMMITMENT.
TO CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND A
LESSER INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE WHEN WE WE
WHEN WE WE WE DO THINGS LIKE
THAT -- SOME OF THE QUESTIONS --
WELL LET'S TALK ABOUT SPECIAL
EDUCATION THAT AT THIS PROPOSAL
AS PROPOSED RIGHT NOW IS TOTALLY
UNWORKABLE -- IT IS REALLY
UNFORTUNATE -- IT [inaudible]
IT.
I I CANNOT SUPPORT IT IT WILL
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE AND
THAT COULD EASE IN OUR SPECIAL
EDUCATION FINANCE SYSTEM.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM
WHAT WE HAVE NOW IS A BEING
FUNDED ADEQUATELY NOW WE'RE
GONNA GO OUT ON I MEAN IT'S LIKE
YOU KNOW YOUR HOUSE ON FIRE
SOULS AND YOU DECIDE AT THE SAME
TIME TO ADD ANOTHER ROOM.
WE NEED TO TAKE CARE OF THE
PROBLEM THAT YOU HAVE NOW BEFORE
YOU VENTURE INTO SOMETHING NEW.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS DOES.
AGAIN IT DOES NOT SOLVE THE
PROBLEM OF NOT ADEQUATELY
FUNDING EXISTING SPECIAL ED.
SERVICES AND IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- THE PROPOSAL
BENEFITS JUST A FEW DISTRICT I
WOULD SAY JUST A FEW MANY
DISTRICTS FOR SURE BUT NOT
ENOUGH -- WE SHOULD REALLY
ADDRESS EQUALIZATION.
BEFORE WE LOOK AT AGAIN GOING
INTO ANOTHER VENTURE OR MAYBE IS
EQUALIZATION PLUS THIS YEAR
PLEASE TAKE A STEP.
THIS YOUR TOWARDS EQUALIZATION I
GET WHAT'S GOING ON HERE WE ALL
KNOW THIS IS ABOUT SOME
DISTRICTS TEETERING.
AND THAT THAT'S PROBABLY WHERE
THE SAME BACK AND I THINK WE'RE
WE MAY NEED TO ADDRESS THAT.
CERTAINLY A THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS WITH THE SAME TIME WE
NEED DRESS THE SPECIALIST SYSTEM
ACROSS OUR STATE THIS PROPOSAL
AS IT SITS COULD ACTUALLY.
ACT AS A DISINCENTIVE TO SERVE
STUDENTS -- BECAUSE THE WAY I
SEE IT RIGHT NOW DISTRICTS THAT.
THERE'S A LOT DISTRICTS THAT ARE
INVESTING IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
OUT OF AND ULTIMATELY THAT KEEPS
OUR SPECIAL ED RATS LOW BECAUSE
THEY'RE HELPING KIDS EARLY.
THE CATCHING THEIR NEEDS EARLY
AND IF THIS MAY ACT AS A
DISINCENTIVE FOR DISTRICTS TO DO
THAT I THINK THAT WOULD.
HARM CHILDREN.
IN OUR STATE AND CERTAINLY HARM
US ON THE FISCAL FRONT.
IN -- IN THE LONG RUN I MEAN
THIS COULD DISCOURAGE EARLY
INTERVENTION AND INCLUSION.
S. OF ROSAL SITS TODAY.
AND IT PUNISHES THE DISTRICTS
THAT ARE A THAT ARE ENGAGED IN
THAT ARE VERY PROACTIVE TODAY --
SO THAT THE THAT'S I HOPE THE
COMMITTEE WILL TAKE A CLOSE LOOK
AT THAT PROPOSAL.
BECAUSE AGAIN I IT'S IT'S JUST
NOT WORKABLE.
AND IT IS NOT THAT SOUND POLICY
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE -- I KNOW
MISTER MEDINA I DON'T LOSE YOUR
HOUSE YOU MISTER MEDIAN I KNOW
HAS A BILL THAT'S BEAST
EQUALIZATION SO AGAIN I HOPE.
EQUALIZATION IS A MAJOR PART OF
THIS COMMITTEES CONVERSATION AS
WE'VE FORMULATE OUR PROPOSAL --
AND ANOTHER QUESTION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- DATA
SHOWS THAT SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS
ATTRACT MORE LOW INCOME STUDENTS
TO THE TEACHING FIELD BECAUSE
LOW INCOME STUDENTS ARE
RELUCTANT TO TAKE ON NEW LOANS.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION IS
FOCUSING ON LOAN FORGET LOAN
FORGIVENESS.
OVER SCHOLARSHIPS AND I DON'T
KNOW IF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAD ANY COMMENT ON THAT.
I JUST WONDER FROM A POLICY
STANDPOINT IF WE SHOULD BE GOING
TO THE PATH OF OF OF
SCHOLARSHIPS AS OPPOSED TO LOAN
FORGIVENESS DOES ANYONE WISH TO
COMMENT ON I CAN I CAN NOT OPINE
SPECIFICALLY.
I DON'T COVER THAT THAT AREA I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
BENEFICIAL COMMENT THAT'S OKAY.
SO JUST REAL QUICK MISTER DONALD
THAT IT'S KIND OF A HYBRID IT'S
OF COURSE EDUCATION TEACHERS BUT
THE PROPOSAL WAS IN THAT HIGHER
ED STUDENT COMMISSIONS WE'LL
TALK ABOUT THAT TOMORROW.
SOUNDS GOOD -- I JUST HAD A
QUESTION ON THE BECOMING ON THE
COMPUTER SCIENCE COORDINATOR
MILLION DOLLARS FOR FOR ONE
PERSON.
IS THAT WOULD THAT WOULD BE.
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO.
I PERSONALLY DO NOT KNOW BUT MY
COLLEAGUES WILL COME SHARE WITH
US.
GOOD MORNING KIMBERLY LEAHY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OF THE
MILLION DOLLARS IS OVER FOUR
YEARS FOR THE POSITION -- IT IS
FOR THE POSITION TO BE A
COORDINATOR AND A POINT PERSON
IN THE IMPLEMENTATION THE
COMPUTER SCIENCE -- PLANNED SO --
IT'S OVER OVER FOUR YEARS NOT
ONE HERE.
THANK YOU AGAIN AND I JUST A
COMMENT FROM SOMEONE TO COME
FROM THE GROUND -- SOMEONE
HASN'T YOU KNOW BEEN OF THE
CLASS FOR MANY YEARS.
WE CREATE A LOT OF THINGS UP
HERE IN SACRAMENTO THAT I DON'T
KNOW THEY REALLY HAVE THE IMPACT
THAT WE LIKE THEM HAVE THE LOCAL
LEVEL CAN.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
COMPUTER SCIENCE EDUCATION IS
GOING TO TAKE PLACE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
THEREFORE WE DO INCENTIVIZE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE PROBABLY WITH DOLLARS.
DEVELOP THE CAPACITY TO TEACH
THINGS LIKE COATING ON THE
SECOND THIRD FOURTH AND BEYOND
GRADES -- I I JUST WORRY
SOMETIMES WERE DATA AND
COORDINATORS ALSO I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY REALLY MEAN.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BECAUSE I
REALLY THINK.
THIS CAPACITY HAS TO BE
DEVELOPED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
I'M I'M OT SURE THAT.
JUST FUNNY OF COURTNEY -- WOULD
DO THAT I THINK SETTING ASIDE
YOU KNOW. SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
ATTACK AGAIN DEVELOP THE
CAPACITY TO TO DELIVER THIS
EDUCATION THE LOCAL LEVEL WITH
THE MONEY MUCH.
BETTER SPENT THANK YOU AND JUST
ONE OTHER COMMENT ON PROPOSITION --
SIXTY FOUR IS.
WE WANT TO SEE I THE PROPOSAL --
SIX TO SEVEN EIGHTY POINT FIVE
MILLION IN PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR FUNDS TO SUBSIDIZE
CHILDCARE FOR SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN AND I JUST WONDER.
WHY WE PUSHING CHILD CARE --
MORE SO THAN THE OUR EXISTING
ASUS PROGRAM.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHICH
TO OPINE ON THE GOOD MORNING
LISA RESIDENTS GIVE A DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SO IT'S NOT THAT IT'S
NOT PUSHING A SAYS I THINK THE
IDEA IS THAT.
OTHER THOUGHT AS THE EARLIER
INTERVENTION -- WITH REGARDS TO
SUBSTANCE ABUSE WOULD BE MORE
ADVANTAGEOUS. FOR ITS GLAZER ONE
MORE TIME SO.
THE PROPOSAL REALLY WASN'T FOR A
SAYS IT'S A SEPARATE PROGRAM I
THINK YOU UNDERSTAND THAT ASUS
IS -- THE IDEA IS THAT THE EARLY
INTERVENTION WITH REGARDS TO
SETTING UP AS A CHILD SPACE --
WOULD LEAD TO BETTER OUTCOMES.
SO WHETHER OR NOT -- SO WHAT
WHAT ARE THEY GONNA DO WITH THE
MONEY.
THEY'RE GOING TO PUT OUT MORE --
ALTERNATE PAYMENTS LOTS FOR
STUDENTS APPROXIMATELY ABOUT
EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED SLOTS FOR
STUDENTS FOR SLOTS FOR WHAT I'M
SORRY FIRST FOR CHILDREN. FOR
CHILDCARE PER CHILD CARE YES
THEIR SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
[inaudible]
CORRECT.
THE SO THE PROPOSAL IS CHANGED
SLIGHTLY SINCE THE EIGHT PAGES
AND AGAIN WE APOLOGIZE FOR THE
CONFUSION.
WITH THIS CHANGE THERE'S WHAT
THERE IS MANY THINGS LOOKED AT
WITH THIS FUNDING AND IT MOVED
RATHER QUICKLY SO THE TALKING
POINTS IN THE EIGHT PAGES ARE.
NOT WHERE WE ARE AT THE PROPOSAL
AT THIS POINT IN TIME SO THAT
I'LL TURN IT SO I DON'T ASK HIM
A QUESTION OF COMMON BECAUSE
WHAT I HAVE IS HERE THAT IT'S
EIGHTY POINT FIVE MILLION FROM
PROP. SIXTY FOUR TO SUBSIDIZE
CHILDCARE FOR SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT SPECIFIC
PROGRAM THEY WOULD BE TALKING
ABOUT MAYBE THE CHAIRED AS BUT
AGAIN I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WOULD
BE BETTER FOLDED IN ASUS.
I THAT THAT THAT'S KIND OF MY MY
QUESTION A YOU KNOW THE ANSWER
RIGHT NOW -- BUT THAT AND ONE
DAUGHTER'S CLOTHES ON FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN SO THESE MISTER
CHAIR -- THE PROPOSAL MAY BE A
NET NEGATIVE FOR THOSE WHO WISH
TO PARTICIPATE IN A THE WAY IT'S
WRITTEN -- BECAUSE IT MAY IMPACT
FUTURE ELIGIBILITY FOR STATE
BOND FUNDS FOR SOME SOME LOCALS
WHO DO.
TAKE THAT MONEY -- SO THE
DISINCENTIVE SHOULD BE CORRECTED
THAT'S RETAIN -- THAT'S FOR
APPLYING OR GETTING -- SOME OF
THAT -- NOW 600- MILLION DOLLARS --
IN -- TO CONVERT THE CANDOR
FACILITY FOR THAT I TURN IT BACK
TO YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU I KNOW WE HAVE A FEW
OTHER QUESTIONS I JUST WANT TO
JUMP RIGHT IN YOU CAN STICK
STICK AROUND HERE FOR FOR THE
PROP SIXTY FOUR I GUESS THERE'S
TWO THINGS THAT I WANTED TO
FOLLOW UP ON ONE THE OBVIOUS
THING.
WHEN I VOTED FOR PROP SIXTY FOUR
ANSWERED ALL OF YOU?
WE THOUGHT TV COMMERCIALS IT
SAID THREE THINGS WE SHOULD TAX
MARIJUANA.
WE SHOULD REGULATE MARIJUANA WE
SHOULD USE THE MONEY FOR
PROGRAMS LIKE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS IT WAS ON THE TV
COMMERCIAL THE CAMPAIGN BROCHURE.
THE BALLOT STATEMENT.
WE LOVE CHILD CARE PROGRAMS BUT
NOT ONCE DID WE TELL THE VOTERS.
IT WOULD EXPAND CHILDCARE
PROGRAM SO THAT'S I THINK A BIG
PROBLEM WITH WHAT WE TOLD THE
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA -- NUMBER
ONE WE SHOULD LOOK AT EXPANDING --
CHILDCARE SLOTS INCLUDING A
PIECE LOTS IN OUR OVERALL BUDGET
BUT I THINK WE'RE PRETTY CLEAR
WITH THE ELECTORATE WHAT THAT
WAS FOR AND I THINK IT'S
DISINGENUOUS.
AND THEN TO THE SECOND ISSUE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT REVISED
NAY REVISED PROPOSAL.
IS NOT GOING TO LOOK AT SCHOOL
AGE CHILDREN IN CHILD CARE BUT
THE EIGHT P. VOUCHERS LOTS WITH
OUR WHICH ARE PREDOMINATELY
LITTLE KIDS AND I'M NOT SURE HOW
YOU DO DRUG INTERVENTION WITH.
TWO AND THREE YEAR OLDS MOST OF
THOSE AFTER MOSTLY EFFORTS FOR
THEIR YOU WOULD THINK ARE FOR
OLDER KIDS WHICH IS WHY.
THE ASUS PROGRAM MAKES SO MUCH
SENSE THOSE OF THE POPULATION
WERE KIDS ARE MOST AT RISK WITH
DABBLING WITH.
DRUGS AND ALCOHOL CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW VAPING AND SO FORTH AND
THAT THE WHEEL HOUSE OF THAT.
IS OF COURSE -- KIDS IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND MIDDLE
SCHOOL SO IT JUST -- DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE SINCE WILL HAVE SOME --
CONCERNS WITH THAT -- WE TURN IT
BACK -- TO MISTER MARTUCCI AND
THEN MISTER GALLAGHER I'LL COME
BACK SOME OTHER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR.
SO I I FEELING A REAL DISCONNECT
BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AND WHAT I'M HEARING FROM SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW WE JUST CAME IN THIS
YEAR WE SAW THE LOS ANGELES
TEACHERS STRIKE.
WHERE YOU KNOW OVERWHELMING --
NUMBERS OF OF LOS ANGELES
RESIDENTS RECOGNIZED.
THAT OUR SCHOOLS ARE WOEFULLY
UNDERFUNDED AND THAT IS THIS WAS
IS IS TRANSLATING INTO THE AT
THE THAT THE CLASS SIZES THE
LACK OF CANCERS A LACK OF NURSES --
IN IN IN IN OUR SCHOOLS.
AND THEN WE MOVED TO OAKLAND AND
WE HAVE THE TEACHERS STRIKE
RAISING THE SAME ISSUES
HIGHLIGHTED THE FACT THAT STATE
FUNDING IS WOEFULLY INADEQUATE.
FOR OUR SCHOOLS AND THEN NOW WE
ARE TURNING TO SACRAMENTO WHERE
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT LAYING OFF
TEACHERS AGAIN BECAUSE THE
WOEFULLY INADEQUATE STATE
FUNDING.
YOU KNOW I'M I'M READING THIS OP
ED THAT WAS JUST IN THE LOS
ANGELES TIMES.
THAT -- THAT TALKS ABOUT HOW.
IN NEW YORK CITY SCHOOLS SPEND
MORE THAN TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
PER PUPIL IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN BOSTON SCHOOL
SPENT MORE THAN TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND I NEED STUDENT.
LOS ANGELES SCHOOLS IN CONTRAST
SPENT ABOUT THIRTEEN THOUSAND
PER STUDENT.
THEY THEY OP ED GOES ON THE
EXPLANATION FOR THIS GLARING
THIS DISCREPANCY AMONG THE
DISTRICTS OBVIOUSLY ISN'T THAT
LOS ANGELES STUDENTS HAVE YOUR
NEEDS.
THE REASON FOR THE DIFFERENCE IS
THAT CALIFORNIA ROUTINELY UNDER
FUNDS AS PUBLIC SCHOOLS WHEN THE
COST OF LIVING IS FACTORED IN
CALIFORNIA CONSISTENTLY RANKS
AMONG THE BOTTOM TEN STATES IN
PER PEOPLE'S.
EXPENDITURES AND SO YOU KNOW
WE'VE BEEN SAYING OVER AND OVER
AGAIN THAT YOU KNOW.
CALIFORNIA IS UNDER FUNDING AT
SCHOOL I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
THE CHAIR OF THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE THAT WE'RE TREATING
PROPOSITION. NINETY NINETY EIGHT
L. AS A AS A CEILING RATHER THAN
A FLOOR AND WE NEED TO STOP
TALKING ABOUT HOW WE ARE YOU
KNOW A BENCH.
OUR OUR PROGRESS BY PROP NINETY
EIGHT BECAUSE PROBLEM NINETY
EIGHT IS THE FLOOR SO.
YOU KNOW AND THEN WHEN I SEE THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL NOTICING THE
SAME THING THAT MR O'DONNELL DID
WERE ACTUALLY GOING IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION IN TERMS OF
THE THE LCF THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA COLA ADJUSTMENT
WE'RE GOING.
FROM WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO
A LOWER NUMBER FROM -- THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS A JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL.
AND WHAT ARE WE TALKING TO THE
SAME PEOPLE ARE WE SEEING THE
SAME THINGS HAPPENING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
CONSISTENTLY SAY THAT EDUCATION
IS OUR NUMBER ONE BUDGET
PRIORITY AND YOU WE WE WE WE PAT
OURSELVES ON THE BACK YOU KNOW
WHAT WHEN WE SAY THAT WE'RE
WE'RE SPENDING MORE ON ON K.
THROUGH TWELVE THAN ANYTHING
ELSE.
BUT WE SHOULD NOT BE MEASURING
OUR PROGRESS BY THIS THIS
MINIMUM GUARANTEE THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT IT IS IS THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEED.
AND I'M SICK AND TIRED OF OU
KNOW -- OF OF THESE BUDGETS THAT --
THAT THAT IS UNDER FUNDING OUR
STATE SCHOOLS THE BLAME IS ON US.
YOU KNOW SHAME ON US FOR UNDER
FUNDING OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEING A LOS
ANGELES THAT'S WERE SEEN OAKLAND
OUTSOURCING SACRAMENTO AND THAT
THAT'S WERE SEEING THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO MISTER CHAIR I AM NOT
INCLINED TO SUPPORT -- THIS
BUDGET I ALSO SHARE THE MISTER
DONALD CONCERNS ABOUT THE
SPECIALIST CATION I THINK.
THE EQUALIZATION SHOULD BE OUR
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IN TERMS OF
ADDRESSING.
OUR SPECIAL EDUCATION --
CHALLENGES I DO APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S.
YOU KNOW OF A PROPOSALS -- TO TO
TO TO HELP OUR SCOOL DISTRICTS
IN IN TERMS OF OUR PENSION
OBLIGATIONS.
BUT YOU KNOW WE WE NEED WE NEED.
TO WE NEED TO FEEL THE URGENCY
THAT WE'RE SEEING IN OUR IN OUR
IN OUR DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
WE NEED TO REALLY STEP UP OUR
COMMITMENT. TO TO OUR K. THROUGH --
TWELVE FUNDING.
OKAY THANK YOU WELL SAID MISTER
MURATSUCHI.
MISTER GALLAGHER.
I MEAN A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS
COVERED AND SOLVED TRY NOT.
TO REITERATE I THINK WITH MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY SAID BUT
I I THINK THE BIGGEST THING FOR
ME IS.
IN THE SPECIAL EDUCATION FRONT I
MEAN MY COLLEAGUES -- FROM LONG
BEACH PUT IT VERY WELL YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT WE'RE CONTINUE TO DO
HERE IS JUST ADD ANOTHER ANOTHER
ROOM WHILE THE HOUSE IS ON FIRE --
AND AND I I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
WE CAN AT LEAST MOVE TOWARDS --
EQUALIZATION FUNDING IN SOME WAY
YOU KNOW EVEN IF IT'S NOT FULL
LEGALIZATION WE CAN START MOVING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION -- ANY OF
THE LA OWES REPORT I THINK JUST
LAID IT OUT EXACTLY ALL THE
PROBLEMS YOU'RE ALLOCATING FUNDS
ACCORDING TO THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
PENALIZES DISTRICTS IT
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS
THAT REDUCE THE NEED FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES DOES THAT ARE.
DOING EARLY INTERVENTION AND AND
HAVING SUCCESS -- THAT DOESN'T
SEEM TO ME TO BE THE RIGHT
APPROACH A NEW CATEGORICAL
PROGRAM WITHOUT EVEN MORE
COMPLEXITY. TO THE STATE'S
EXISTING PATCHWORK OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
EXACTLY YEAH AND SO THAT'S WHY
WE'RE TRYING TO SAY LET'S GO TO
OTHER ALTERNATIVES YOU KNOW.
SUCH AS FUNDING EQUALIZATION
WOULD DISTRIBUTE THE FUNNY MORE
BROADLY AND REDUCE THE
HISTORICAL FUNDING INEQUITIES
WITHOUT CREATING FISCAL
INCENTIVES.
IT FISCAL INCENTIVES TO KEEP
STUDENTS IN SPECIAL EDUCATION.
MAN I WOULD NOTICE MEETING WAS
SO MYSELF AS HERE LOCALLY I MEAN
A LOT OF THESE SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS ARE NOT JUST DEALING
WITH KIDS.
WITH THE CANNOT JUST BE HELPFUL
THE KIDS THAT ARE IN I. E. PEAS.
THEY CAN BE HELPFUL KIDS OR DEAL
WITH A LOT OTHER ISSUES.
MENTAL HEALTH.
OTHER THINGS THAT WERE SEEN IN A
IN OURS IN OUR SCHOOLS -- YOU
KNOW SO LOOK I JUST THINK THIS
IS THE COMPLETE WRONG APPROACH.
AND YOU KNOW I'M REALLY HOPING
THAT YOU KNOW I I I FEEL LIKE
THAT'S THE TENOR OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND AND I THINK ALSO ON THE
SENATE SIDE IS THAT WE PUSH
FORWARD.
TOWARDS MORE OF A OF A
EQUALIZATION FUNDING -- METHOD --
AND SO I AM HOPING THAT WE CA
DO THAT I WOULD ECHO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT.
YOU KNOW MY COLLEAGUE MADE.
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT WHY NOT
FOCUS ON ACES I MEAN ACES WE
WERE JUST HAD A MEETING ON THIS.
HEARING ON THIS LAST WEEK --
WHERE WE TALKED ABOUT THESE
GREAT PROGRAMS THAT ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED THROUGH THE ASUS
FUNDING -- AND I FEEL LIKE WE'RE
SORT OF SHORT CHANGING THAT AND
I THINK WE HAVE.
TO I REALIZE THAT THE CHILD CARE
DISCUSSION KINDA GETS CAUGHT UP
IN THE IN THE PRE K. AND AND BUT
THEY ARE DIFFERENT.
THEY ARE TWO DIFFERENT THINGS
YOU KNOW AND I I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD LOOK AT EDUCATION AS
CHILD CARE.
NECESSARILY RIGHT -- AND AND
MAYBE THAT'S SORT OF THE PROBLEM
LIKE.
WE ARE EXPECTING MORE MORE MORE
OF OUR TEACHERS AND EDUCATORS TO
DO THINGS THAT REALLY ARE.
NOT THEIR RESPONSIBILITY AND AND
IT'S EXPENSIVE FOR THEM TO DO
ALL OF THOSE DIFFERENT THINGS.
AND SO.
I THINK WE NEED TO REALLY WORK
ON HOW WE SEPARATE THAT OUT A
LITTLE BIT CERTAINLY THERE'S
THERE IS THERE IS A NEED FOR
WORKING PARENTS.
CHILD CARE COSTS ARE EXTREMELY
HIGH -- YOU KNOW TO TO FIGURE
THAT.
YOU KNOW TO HAVE SOME RESOURCES
THERE BUT I DON'T WANNA MAKE SET
UP WITH WHAT ARE LEGITIMATE.
WHAT WHAT WHAT?
THE FOCUS OF OUR BUT IT SHOULD
BE WHICH IS EDUCATING.
OUR KIDS AND ENSURING THAT THEY
HAVE THE TOOLS TO SUCCEED -- AND
THAT THAT'S WHERE OUR EDUCATION
DOLLARS HAVE TO BE FOCUSED THEY
HAVE TO BE FOCUSED ON THAT.
ON THAT EFFORT AND SO -- YOU
KNOW THAT WOULD BE MY COMMENTS
AND BUT THAT'LL JUST TURNED BACK
TO THE CHAIR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT TO MY JOB IN A COUPLE
THESE THESE ISSUES TO AN AND MAY
BE ALLOWED DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO I'M ON THE SPECIAL AT I
CONCUR THAT IT'S AN ISSUE THAT.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS AND PUT MORE
RESOURCES INTO AND WE WE HAD A A
OP INFORMATIONAL HEARING ABOUT
THIS -- LAST I THINK TWO YEARS
IN A ROW NOW.
AND HERE FOR FROM DISTRICTS ALL
OUR DOWNSTATE AND THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS AND SPECIAL THAT ARE
GOING UP AS ARE THE COSTS OF THE
THE ATTENTION THIS IS IMPORTANT.
BUT THE REMEDY IN THE PROPOSAL
JUST ISN'T FAIR -- IT LOOKS LIKE
IT HELPS LOS ANGELES
SIGNIFICANTLY AND THEY LIKE THE
PROPOSAL AND YOU KNOW THEY'RE
HURTING.
BUT A LOT OF OTHER DISTRICTS ARE
HURTING AS WELL.
SO WANTED TO GIVE YOU THE CHANCE
YOU HEARD ALL OF OUR MEMBERS --
TALK ABOUT THIS AND A WHAT ARE
WE MISSING HERE AND AND WHY
WON'T YOU CONSIDER THE
EQUALIZATION APPROACH AS OPPOSED.
TO THE PROPOSAL IN THE BUDGET SO
FIRST OF ALL LET ME WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CONCERNS AND WE
HAVE BEEN AN ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS I WILL CONTINUE
THIS CONVERSATION OUTGOING THIS
PROPOSAL REALLY IS DEDICATED.
TO ADDRESS SEEN -- KIND OF
EQUITY ISSUES IN A SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND ITS TARGETS THE
HIGH -- IMPACT AREAS SUCH AS
YOUR LOW INCOME SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS SIR.
AND THE FUNDING IS DEDICATED
REALLY TOOK TRYING.
TO PROVIDE MORE FUNDING FOR
EARLY INTERVENTION FOR THE
STUDENTS THERE AREN'T THAT TEND
TO HAVE MORE AND HIGHER NEEDS
MAYBE NOT NECESSARILY SPECIAL
EDUCATION NEEDS BUT IT COULD
LEAD TO SPECIAL EDUCATION.
I'M AND IMPROVED OUTCOMES IS IS
OUR THOUGHT.
IT IS CERTAINLY NOT THAT WEREN'T.
EQUITY A GIVE EQUALIZATION IS
NOT PART OF OUR CONVERSATION
BECAUSE WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT NOT
ALL DISTRICTS BENEFIT FROM
EQUALIZATION -- BUT WE DO THINK
THAT WE'RE WE'RE WILLING TO HAVE
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WITH WITH
REGARDS TO THE FORMULA.
YEAH.
I THINK AND THINKING ABOUT THE
OVERALL PROP NINETY EIGHT ISSUE.
I CONCUR WITH OUR EDUCATION
CHAIR MISTER O'DONNELL.
IN MISTER MARTUCCI WHOSE LEAD IN
THAT CONVERSATION ON TAKING A
LOOK AT LCF AFFAN ITS ADEQUACY.
AND THERE RIGHT IT'S IT'S A
DISGRACE THAT WORD WOEFULLY
UNDER FUNDING OUR SCHOOLS --
FORTY FIRST THE NATION CERTAINLY
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS COULD MAKE
BETTER DECISIONS MY OWN DISTRICT
RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
I THINK THEY MADE -- SOME REALLY
TERRIBLE BUDGET DECISIONS TO GET
IN THIS PROBLEM AND THEY NEED
OWN TO BALANCING THEIR CHECKBOOK
RIGHT OR WRONG BUT THE BIG
PICTURE IS THAT.
WE ARE STARVING OUR OUR
DISTRICTS WHEN YOU LOOK AT OUR
HIGH COST OF LIVING AND WHAT THE
TEACHERS NEED TO GET TO MAKE A
LIVING WE SAW THE ARTICLE FEW
WEEKS GO IN THAT.
AREA AND TEACHERS THERE -- THEY
CAN EVEN.
IF THEY CAME TO LIVE OUTSIDE OF
THEIR YOU KNOW GRANDMA'S HOUSE
SIR.
JOINING UP AS YOU SAID KITE YOU
KNOW THREE AND FOUR TEACHERS PER
AN APARTMENT AND THAT'S WHY IT
COSTS SO MUCH. TO TO RUN OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND IN SO MANY
THEIR COUNTIES ACROSS THIS GUY.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA NOT TO MENTION YOU
KNOW ALL THE OTHER FIXED COSTS
WITH -- RETIREMENT AND HEALTH
CARE AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT I THINK
MORE THAN JUST THIS BUDGET BUT
THE TECH TALK IN THE VOTERS
BECAUSE I I DON'T THINK WE CAN
COMPLAIN ABOUT WILL FULLY --
FUNDING OUR SCHOOLS.
AND HAVE THE FUNDING ABOUT HALF
OF WHAT YOU SAID NEW YORK AND
MASSACHUSETTS HAVE.
NOT BE WILLING TO GO TO THEM AND
SAYING WHAT YOU WILLING TO PAY
YOU CAN HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO DO THAT
AND AN UPCOMING BALLOT BUT THE
PROBLEM.
IS TODAY AND TODAY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET.
AND I I THINK IT'S SO HARD FOR
THE AVERAGE VOTER TO UNDERSTAND
CONSTITUENTS UNDERSTAND THAT WE
HEAR ABOUT THIS TWENTY PLUS.
BILLION DOLLARS SURPLUS GRANTED
MAJORITY OF IT IS ONE TIME.
AND I KNOW THE GOVERNOR
RIGHTFULLY HAS TRIED AT THE
SAYING WE'VE INCREASED FUNDING.
THE LAST FIVE YEARS BY 50% THIS
HIGHEST AMOUNT OF FUNDING
CALIFORNIA HISTORY YOU KNOW TELL
THAT TO DISTRICTS ARE SENDING
OUT PINK SLIPS TODAY.
IT DOESN'T REALLY HELP THEM AND
SO WITH ALL WE HAVE AN ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S -- A PRIORITIES --
THIS IS DOESN'T LOOK LIKE THIS
DOES NOT LOOK LIKE IT'S BEING
ADEQUATELY -- PRIORITIZED AND SO
THAT IS -- GREATLY DISAPPOINTING
AND CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT YOU
KNOW WORK ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS
AS WE CLOSE OUT -- THE BUDGET --
THIS YEAR.
THAT'S KIND OF MORE OF A
COMMENTARY NOT NOT A QUESTION
THERE.
I DID WANT -- TO ALSO ASK ABOUT
THE WHO WHO WAS WHICH YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE THE ECM PROJECTS THAT
YOU.
I'M INTERESTED WHAT WHAT WHAT.
YEAH SEPARATE QUESTIONS.
GOTCHA GOTCHA.
YES SO IN THE PROPOSAL YOU YOU
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET AS
FAR AS THE NUMBER OF SLOTS AND
RESOURCES AVAILABLE BE CHANGED.
THE THE OUT YEAR AS YOU ACTUALLY
YEAH YEAH THE I'M YOU CHANGE THE
OUT YEAR AND THAT THE PRESCHOOL
FOR ALL KIND OF PROMISE SO --
WHY IS IT NECESSARY -- TO TO
ADDRESS THAT IN THIS YEAR'S --
BUDGET CONCLUSION WHEN IT'S
REALLY KIND OF AN OUT YEAR
CONVERSATION AND COMMITMENT.
SO I APOLOGIZE SO YOU'RE
WONDERING WHY WE REMOVETHE
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLAR SO WITH
PART OF THE AS YOU KNOW
BUDGETING BALANCING THE BUDGET
IS NOT A ONE YEAR -- COMMITMENT
IT'S IT'S OUT SEVERAL YEARS FIVE
YEARS I BELIEVE AND ONE OF THE
THINGS WE NOTICED AS WE GOT THE
NOON ECONOMIC INDICATORS IS THAT
REVENUES ARE DROPPING MORE
SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE OUT YEARS
THAN WE HAD ANTICIPATED.
SO IN ORDER TO BALANCE THE
BUDGET IN THE OUT YEARS WE WE
REMOVE THE SLOTS NOT NECESSARILY
THE COMMITMENT TO THE SPOTS BUT
WE REMOVE THE FUNDING.
IN ORDER TO KIND OF RE GAUGING
NEXT YEAR WITH THE NEW ECONOMIC
INDICATORS ON HOW MUCH THE STATE
CAN AFFORD GOING FORWARD SO
THERE IS A COMMITMENT -- INTO IT
WOULD GET TO UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL
WE ALSO ARE HOPING THAT THE
MASTER PLAN THAT'S BEEN UP
PROPOSED WILL ALSO GIVE US A
BETTER OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE THE
PRESCHOOL ARE THE SLOTS THAT ARE
NEEDED IN THE STATE.
IT MAY BE T. K. IT MAY BE --
ZERO FOUR ZERO TO FIVE OTHER
AREAS SO I THINK ALL IDEAS WE
NEED A NEEDS ASSESSMENT IN THE
STATE ON EARLY LEARNING IN THIS
AREA WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND HOW
WE CAN BETTER FUND IT WITH NOT.
ONLY GENERAL FUND BUT LEVERAGING
OTHER RESOURCES WITHIN THE STATE --
AND IN DETERMINING WHAT POCKETS
THE STATE THAT DID THAT OF SORTS
THAT ARE USUALLY SPOKE UP NEED
THIS THE MOST SO.
IT'S NOT THE COMMITMENT.
THAT'S BEEN REMOVED IT'S JUST
REALLY AT STEPPING BACK AND
TAKING A LOOK AT WHAT'S THE
STATE CAN AFFORD TO DO GOING
FORWARD AND AS FAR AS THE THE
ACES CONVERSATION THE AFTER
SCHOOL -- PROGRAM -- ONE I KNOW
THAT THE STATE LAST COUPLE YEARS
HAS TAKEN A LOOK AT ISSUES LIKE.
I TO ASSESS AND HOME CARE
INDUSTRY -- CERTAINLY ARE EARLY
EDUCATION OUR OUR OUR OUR
PRESCHOOL AND AND CHILD CARE
WORK FORCE.
AND REALIZE THAT COSTS HAVE GONE
UP CITIES HAVE ENACTED MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASES CALIFORNIA.
HAS IT AS WELL.
AND YOU KNOW IF YOU DON'T
INCREASE -- REV IF YOU INCREASE
THE RESOURCES FOR THE PROGRAM
SIDE TO SIMPLE LAWS OF
MATHEMATICS AND THE YOUR FEET
YOU'LL SIR FEWER KIDS SO HOW DO
YOU ATTEMPT TO RECONCILE THAT.
WITH OUR STATE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM.
AND WE HEARD FROM THEM A FEW
WEEKS AGO SAYING THAT -- YOU
KNOW THEY'RE GOING -- TO
DECREASE THE NUMBER OF KIDS
SERVICE IN OUR COMMUNITY SAID
THAT.
WON'T HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT FOR
FOR FAMILIES FOR STUDENTS SHE
MEANT.
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY HAZARD FROM
ALL OVER ADVOCATE SOME.
WHAT IS THAT WE HAVE ALSO HEARD
FROM THE UP THE KIDS AND WE DO
APPRECIATE AND AND RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM IT'S ALSO A PROGRAM
THAT'S LEVERAGED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL IT'S IT'S SHOULD BE A
LOCAL PRIORITY TO HAVE HELP?
FUND THESE AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
THAT THAT WAS ALWAYS MEANT TO BE
THE STATE CONTRIBUTION WAS ONLY
A PORTION OF THE FULL FUNDING --
BUT AGAIN IT'S IT'S A MATTER OF
LIMITED ON GOING FUNDING AND THE
ABILITY TO TAKE THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS THEY REQUEST.
UP AWAY FROM SOMEONE ELSE THAT
ALSO PROBABLY NEED THAT SO I I
MEAN THAT'S THE SITUATION AND AS
YOU GO TO BALANCE THE BUDGET
YOU'RE PUTTING TOGETHER YOUR
FOURTH YOUR PROPOSAL YOU WILL.
YOU WILL COME ACROSS THE SAME
AND WE KNOW THAT AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS OUR CHILD CARE FOR A
LOT.
BROWNLEE -- THAT THE
PARTICIPANTS IN THOSE PROGRAMS I
JUST WONDER IF YOU CAN ADDRESS
THE FACT THAT AS I SAID A FEW
TIMES BEFORE WHEN WE CAMPAIGNED
ON THIS WHEN.
FRANKLY THE GOVERNOR WAS THE
LEADER IN THIS CAMPAIGN PROP.
SIXTY FOUR HE TALKED ABOUT AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND I BROUGHT
THE TV COMMERCIAL HERE.
LAST HEARING AND I READ THE
BALLOT STATEMENT.
I READ THE THE BALLOT ARGUMENTS
AND IT SAID AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND NEVER SAID.
CHILD CARE INFANT TODDLER
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE IMPORTANT I
DON'T WANT TO MISS THOSE SO.
HOW DO YOU RECONCILE THAT THAT
THE PROMISE TO THE ELECTORATE IS --
A YEAR AND A HALF LATER AND KIND
OF IGNORED.
SO I BELIEVE THAT THE USE WITH
THE APS LOTS DOES FIT THE
WORDING MAYBE NOT THE TELEVISION
COMMERCIALS BUT IF YOU READ THE
ACTUAL PROPOSITION SCHOOL
RETENTION.
OF IMPROVED OUTCOMES YOU KNOW.
ADDRESSED IT LOWER IN SUBSTANCE
ABUSE ARE ALL PART OF IT -- SO
WE DO THINK THAT THE AP AND
GIVING THE SLOTS.
TOO YOUNG FAMILIES AND HELPING
THE BASE OF THAT FAMILY -- HAVE
BETTER CIRCUMSTANCES AS HELPFUL
A LOT OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE IS
ACTUALLY DEVELOPED OVER THE
DEEPER CALAMITY FOR IT IS.
EARLY IN AGE -- SO WHERE DOES IT
TELL YOU ANYTHING -- AS THEIR
CATCHER AND TAKING TO PROGRAMS
AGAINST EACH OTHER READ THE AT
THE AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM OR
SAYING WHAT ABOUT US.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO THROW.
YOU KNOW THE A. P. AND CHILD
CARE.
FAMILIES UNDER THE BUS AND SO WE
REALLY ARE COUNTING ON ON THE
BUDGET TO VALUE BOTH OF THESE.
AND SO THAT'S THE DISAPPOINTING
THING IS YOU KNOW WE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO BE.
LOOKING AT THE BAD GUYS SOLUTION
HERE AND CAN PICKING WINNERS AND
LOSERS WHEN -- I THINK THAT --
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT.
PROP SIXTY FOUR TALK ABOUT AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
THEY HAD ONE WORDS ON THE TV
COMMERCIAL ONE SLOGAN.
A ONE WORD AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
[inaudible]
NOTHING ELSE -- OKAY
YES -- ONE MORE QUESTION FOR THE
FOR THE LA -- SO YOUR REVENUE
PROJECTIONS WERE A LITTLE BIT
HIGHER THAN THE NUMBERS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND IN ORDER STANDING AT DOESN'T
HAVE MUCH OF AN IMPACT ON
SCHOOLS AND AND PROP NINETY
EIGHT CAN YOU ELABORATE ON THAT
A LITTLE BIT.
SURE I'LL DO MY BEST I THINK
THERE MIGHT BE YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE STILL KIND OF WORKING WITH.
THE ADMINISTRATION AND WE
THINKING ABOUT THE DIFFERENCES
AND WHY THEY ARE BUT I THINK ONE
FACTOR IS THAT WE WE PREPARE OUR
ESTIMATES A LITTLE BIT LATER
THAN THE ADMINISTRATION SO WE
HAVE A LITTLE BIT BETTER DATA
MORE RECENT DATA ON WHAT
HAPPENED IN APRIL IN SOME OF THE
MORE.
RECENT I TAX COLLECTIONS AND WE
CAN INCORPORATE THAT IN OUR
OUTLOOK.
WE ALSO I THINK ANOTHER FACTOR
IS -- ALL THESE INITIAL PUBLIC
OFFERINGS OF CALIFORNIA BASED
COMPANIES IT'S A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT KIND OF REVENUE BUMP
FROM THAT WE JUST HAVE DIFFERENT
WAYS OF MODELING AT I THINK OUR
IS.
KIND OF MODEL ASSUMES A LITTLE
BIT MORE SLIGHTLY MORE REVENUE
FROM THOSE KINDS OF OFFERINGS --
SO WE'RE STILL KIND OF WORKING
TO MAKE SURE WE UNDERSTAND ALL
OF THE PIECES -- BUT WE THINK
THOSE TWO ARE PART OF IT AND IN
KIND OF THE BROADER ECONOMIC
OUTLOOK WE ARE VERY SIMILAR -- I
THINK FOR LIKE THE REVENUE THAT
AFFECTS PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT OR MAYBE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION.
BELOW THE ADMINISTRATION AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION PER YEAR ABOVE THEM AND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN NINETEEN
TWENTY YOU KNOW THE CONTEXT OF A
HUNDRED AND FORTY BILLION IN
GENERAL FUND REVENUE THAT'S
THAT'S ABOUT AS CLOSE AS YOU'RE
LIKELY TO SEE IN A IN TWO
DIFFERENT OUTLOOKS.
OKAY THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LIMA.
I THINK I JUST WANTED TO CHIME
IN -- AS THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS ON THE
CONVERSATION BETWEEN THE KIND OF
PITTING.
OF EARLY CHILDHOOD CARE US LOTS
WITH AFTER SCHOOL SLOTS -- AND
WHILE.
I THINK THAT THE THERE HAS BEEN
JUSTIFICATION MADE THAT LEGALLY
THE BALLOT LANGUAGE ALLOWS FOR
THAT I THINK THAT IT'S NOT IN
THE SPIRIT OF WHAT OUR PARTNERS --
NINE AND ALSO WHAT THE PUBLIC
THINKS AND SO I WOULD ASKS FOR
RECONSIDERATION ON THAT FACT I
GET IT.
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN PART OF
BALLOT INITIATIVES AS WELL AND
WE CAN LEGALLY JUSTIFY THEM BUT
IN THE LAST TWENTY FOUR HOURS
THE CONVERSATION WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN BOTH -- EARLY
CHILDHOOD AT CARE -- SPOTS AS
WELL AS AFTER SCHOOL SPOTS HAS.
CLEARLY I THINK REFLECTED THE
HEADING OF EACH OTHER -- AND I
WOULD HOPE THAT.
WE CAN FIND WAYS TO WORK
TOGETHER AND MAKE THESE
DECISIONS COLLECTIVELY BUT I
HOPE THAT THAT MESSAGES
UNDERSTOOD THAT OUR PARTNERS WHO
GO OUT WITH US TO GET BALLOTS
PASSED. TO MOVE INITIATIVES
FORWARD TO FIND AND IDENTIFY --
FUNDING -- SHOULDN'T BE PITTED
AGAINST EACH OTHER IN A
SITUATION LIKE THIS -- I THINK
IT TOOK THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS --
OFF GUARD A BIT THAT IT WAS DONE
SO IN SUCH A WAY AND I GET IT
LEGALLY WE CAN DO IT BECAUSE THE
BALLOT INITIATIVES ARE PURPOSELY
RATE AND IN VEGAS AND YOU KNOW
BROAD LANGUAGE TO BE HAVE SOME
FLEXIBILITY -- BUT IN TERMS OF
OUR LONG.
TERM PARTNERSHIP A THINK IT'S
GOING CAUSE BIGGER PROBLEMS SO --
THOSE CONVERSATIONS ARE
HAPPENING AS I SPEAK BETWEEN
PARTNERS -- BETWEEN MEMBERS OF
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS -- IN BOTH
HOUSES BUT I I HOPE THAT IT'S
UNDERSTOOD THAT THIS IS REALLY A
CHALLENGE -- FOR BOTH HOUSES.
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO MAKE IT
REAL VERY CLEAR THAT IT WAS NOT
THE INTENT OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION TO PET ANYONE
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER FOR WITH
THESE -- WITH THIS PROPOSAL AND
CERTAINLY -- WE HAVE ALSO HEARD
YOUR CONCERNS VERY STRONGLY OVER
THE LAST FEW DAYS AND WITH THE
IN JOINT ONGOING CONVERSATION TO
RECTIFY.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI ONCE
AGAIN.
THANK YOU I WANT TO COME BACK TO
MY FAVORITE TOPIC THERE'S TALK
ABOUT EARLIER -- SO.
I KNOW YOU ARE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND MAY OR
MAY NOT BE ABLE -- TO REPRESENT
THE GOVERNOR -- BUT IS THE
GOVERNOR COMFORTABLE WITH
CALIFORNIA BEING FORTY FOURTH IN
THE NATION IN PER PEOPLE
SPENDING.
I THINK.
I THINK I WOULD JUST.
COMMENT AND SAY I MEAN WE WE HAD
A PER PUPIL FUNDING HEARING HERE
I BELIEVE EARLIER THIS YEAR --
TALKING ABOUT HOW YOU KNOW A LOT
OF THOSE RANKINGS.
SOME TAKEN BECAUSE LIVING SOME
DON'T -- I THINK WE'RE NOT
REALLY IN A POSITION -- TO PINUS
THAT BECAUSE REALLY THE MOST
RECENT DATA WITH ALL THE RECENT
INFLUX IS AN FUNDING UNDER THE
LC FF.
REALLY HAVING TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT YET WHEN TO COME UP --
QUITE SIGNIFICANTLY AS YOU HEARD
US IN THE ALLEY -- SHARE -- THAT
HEARING I MENTIONED SO -- I
THINK AT THIS POINT WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE A POSITION OUR
COMMENT TO THAT QUESTION
DIRECTLY.
OKAY WELL I I I'VE BEEN.
RIGHT I STARTED HERE IN IN IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND I KNOW THAT --
EVER SINCE AROUND -- TWENTY
TWELVE WE I I BELIEVE THE STATE
HAS -- RESTORED OVER THIRTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS AND AND AND K.
THROUGH TWELVE FUNDING.
AND YET I'VE I'VE NEVER SEEN
CALIFORNIA MOVE HIGHER THAN I
THINK MAYBE FORTY FIRST IN THE
NATION IN PER PUPIL SPENDING.
YOU KNOW TAKING THE EDUCATION
WEEKLY NUMBERS ADJUSTING FOR
COST OF LIVING WHICH I THINK
REFLECTS THE THE REALITY OF
LIVING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- ASSUMING THAT WE
ARE AND THE AND THE AT BEST IN
THE BOTTOM HALF A RATHER THAN --
YOU KNOW -- YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
WHAT THE LOS ANGELES TIMES SO
CITED IN THERE OUGHT EDITORA
EARLIER IN IN TERMS OF THE
DRAMATICALLY HIGHER PER PEOPLE
SPENDING THAT WE'RE SEEING --
AND STATES -- YOU KNOW
ESPECIALLY THOSE ON THE EAST
COAST DOES THE GOVERNOR HAVE A
PLAN ON HOW TO INCREASE
CALIFORNIA'S PER PEOPLE SPENDING.
I WOULDN'T SAY IT AT THIS POINT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS A
SPECIFIC PLAN IN TERMS OF YOU
KNOW MAYBE A WAY TO GENERATE
ADDITIONAL REVENUES OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT -- NOW -- BUT THAT IS
CERTAINLY.
PART OF THE CONVERSATION WE TALK
ABOUT COMPARING OTHER STATES IS
THAT CALIFORNIA.
WELL WE'RE UNIQUE IN A IN A LOT
OF WAYS BUT ALSO JUST OUR MIX OF
PROPERTY TAX IN GENERAL FUND
THAT GOES TOWARDS.
FUNDING EDUCATION VERSUS STATES
LIKE NEW YORK IT IT'S A WHOLE
OTHER THE RATIO IS COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT WHILE THESE OTHER
STATES SO I JUST COMMENT THAT
BUT BUT IN ANSWER QUESTIONS NOW.
DOES THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DISPUTE THESE NUMBERS THAT ARE
CITED BY THE LOS ANGELES TIMES
AT IN NEW YORK CITY SCHOOL SPENT
MORE THAN TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
PER PEOPLE.
BOSTON SPENT MORE THAN TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND PER STUDENT.
WELL WE'RE AS IN COMPARISON LOS
ANGELES -- AT LEAST UNDER THE
LCF APHID IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S
INCREASED ABOUT SIXTEEN THOUSAND
BUT STILL -- DATE DOES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DISPUTE
THAT THAT -- JUST TAKING THOSE
THREE CITIES AS AN EXAMPLE THAT
WE ARE THAT THE THAT THESE --
FIGURES ARE MORE OR LESS
ACCURATE.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THEM PERSONALLY
SO I CAN'T REALLY SAY BUT I KNOW
LOOKING AT RANKINGS TYPICALLY
NEW YORK IS IS VERY HIGH SO IT
DOESN'T SOUND -- ON REASONABLE I
SUPPOSE YOU COULD SAY.
OUR THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THIS IS INFORMATIONAL
TODAY WE WILL NOT BE.
TAKING ANY ACTIONS.
WE NOW WILL.
THANK YOU CAN BE DISMISSED
PLEASE.
I WILL NOW PROCEED WITH PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
THE PLEASE LINE UP IN THE MIDDLE.
THANK YOU
[inaudible]
START.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS RON RAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS A VERY GOOD
CONVERSATION THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTIONS IN THE COMMENTS -- IT
WE CERTAINLY DO APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS TO PUBLIC EDUCATION
HOWEVER -- ALL OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS BROUGHT THIS POINT UP
THAT WE ARE STILL.
IN THE BOTTOM -- TEN STATES IN
TERMS OF PER PUPIL FUNDING
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THERE ARE
LOTS OF THINGS IN THE BUDGET THE
MAY REVISE THAT WE DO LIKE -- WE
DO LIKE THE ADDITION OF THE CAL
STIRS CONTRIBUTION -- THE THREE
POINT ONE FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
WILL CERTAINLY HELP SCHOOL
DISTRICTS -- WE WOULD LIKE.
TO REQUEST THAT THE ASSEMBLY
LOOK AT PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS IN TERMS OF PAYING DOWN
THE LIABILITY FOR CALPERS AS
WELL WE LIKE THE TEACHER SERVICE
CREDIT SCHOLARSHIP OF EIGHTY
NINE POINT NINE MILLION.
WE LIKE THE TEACHER PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING WE SHARE
CONCERNS WITH THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION -- DISTRIBUTION MODEL
WE THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE --
REVISITED WE SUPPORT
EQUALIZATION -- IN TERMS OF THE
RAINY DAY FINE WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IT IS CONSTITUTIONALLY
REQUIRED TO PUT THOSE DOLLARS
INTO.
THE RAINY DAY FUND BUT WE WE
THINK THAT'S A BIT PROBLEMATIC I
THINK IT WILL BE DIFFICULT FOR
SCHOOLS TO ACCESS THOSE DOLLARS --
AND THEY'RE COUNTED AGAINST OUR
PROP NINETY EIGHT ALLOCATION.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY
THANK YOU AND JUST FOR THE
CALPERS.
QUESTION YOU'RE ASKED ABOUT THIS
TO BUY DOWN FOR CALPERS JUST FOR
EDUCATION.
CORRECT YES THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS NANCY TRIES
TO SPIN OFFS ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING FIRST I WANT TO THANK
YOU OFFER A VERY ENGAGING
DISCUSSION WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT LEVEL OF OF A
COMMITMENT.
AB FIRST I WANT TO ADDRESS AN
ISSUE THAT -- MISTER O'DONNELL
RAISED REGARDING THE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM -- THE
INCREASE STATE MATCH IS ACTUALLY
UNNECESSARY BECAUSE MOST OF
THOSE ONLY A IS ALREADY QUALIFY
FOR FINANCIAL HARDSHIP WHICH
MEANS THEY ALREADY RECEIVE UP TO
A 100% OF THEIR PROJECTED COSTS
FROM THE STATE SO WELL INTENDED
AND APPRECIATED BUT WE ACTUALLY
DON'T THINK THAT MEASURE IS
NECESSARY.
THE OTHER PIECE A FULL DAY
CANDOR IS THAT -- THE MAY REVISE
STILL FAILS TO ADDRESS THE
DISINCENTIVE CREATED BECAUSE OF
THE THE THE ELIMINATION OF
ELIGIBILITY FOR OF THE STATE
SCHOOL BOND PROGRAM THE STATE
SCHOOL FACILITIES PROGRAM SO WE
WOULD HELP THE COMMITTEE ADDRESS
THAT.
AND BRIEFLY I WANT TO ADDRESS AN
ISSUE -- THAT IS BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE BUT WAS NOT IN THE MAY
REVISION WHICH IS THE CONTINUING
BACKLOG OF PROGRAMS AT THIS A
PROJECTS THE STATE SCHOOL
FACILITIES PROGRAM.
SO THE THE ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO PROPOSE ONLY ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION IN BOND SALES
AND PROGRAM A PORTION AND
PROJECT PORTION MEN'S -- THE PSE
HAS ALREADY RECEIVED FIVE
BILLION INCOMPLETE APPLICATIONS
THAT ARE WITHIN EXISTING
AUTHORITY AND THAT BACKLOG
CONTINUES TO GROW -- CASH
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE BOND SALES
OVER LAST YEAR BUT WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE THAT A HIGHER ANNUAL
TARGET A PROP FIFTY ONE
APPORTIONMENT.
AND PROVIDE -- PSE WITH THE
STAFFING RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
MEET THAT TARGET THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS BRENDAN
TO IT ON BEHALF OF CAN DANGLE A
LARGE NONPROFIT EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION AND EARLY CARE
PROVIDER IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA -- WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S CONTINUED.
COMMITMENT TO EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION -- BUT WE DO UNDER
SCORE THE NEED FOR FURTHER
INVESTMENT IN HIGH QUALITY --
INFANT AND TODDLER SLOTS ALSO
INCLUDING GENERAL CHILDCARE
SLOTS.
AND JUST TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA AT
KID AND GO FOR EVERY SPACE THAT
WE HAVE FOR INFANTS AND TODDLERS
THERE'S SEVEN VERY YOUNG
CHILDREN -- ON THE WAITING LIST
SO -- WE WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS AS YOU
MOVE FORWARD WITH YOUR BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MIGHT THE GUERRERO REPRESENTING
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND ALONG WITH --
THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM CAN
DANGLE WE ARE ALSO -- REALLY
COULD CONCERNED AND NOT MEETING
THE NEEDS FOR OUR EARLY LEARNERS
LA COUNTY IS HOME TO AN
ESTIMATED THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVEN CHILDREN.
FROM BIRTH TO FIVE YEARS OLD
RESIDED IN LOW INCOME FAMILIES
OF WHICH 79% LIKE AXIS IT'S TO
SUBSIDIZED EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION SERVICES.
AND MOST ALARMING 93% OF BABIES
AND TODDLERS OF INCOME ELIGIBLE
FAMILIES COMPARED 260% OF
PRESCHOOLERS.
ARE UNABLE TO ACCESS THE
SERVICES.
IN ADDITION -- WE WOULD LIKE --
TO GET THE BY FOR KATIE
REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM -- RATE
SYSTEM ADDRESSED IT LIMITS
ACCESS AND DOES NOT REALLY
COMPENSATED EDUCATED AND SKILLED
WORK FORCE NOR MEETS THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH MEETING THE
STANDARDS OF HIGH QUALITY EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
SO WE ASK THAT YOU -- ALSO FUND
THE BIRTH TO FIVE YEARS OLD AND
ADDRESS THE BIFURCATED
REIMBURSEMENT RATES SYSTEM THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING DAVE ALL RATS
REPRESENTING SCHOOL ENERGY
COALITION.
A WHILE THE MAYBE VISION DID NOT
INCLUDE FUNDS TO CONTINUE THE
VERY SUCCESSFUL ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAM A PROPOSITION.
THIRTY NINE WE HOPE IN THE
LEGISLATURE CREATES ITS
PRIORITIES FOR THE BUDGET.
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO CONSIDER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
GONZALEZ'S REQUEST FOR FUNDING
TO CONTINUE THAT PROGRAM IT IS A
GRANT PROGRAM.
WHICH MEANS IT CAN BE DONE WITH
ONE TIME MONEY.
AND AS A GRANT PROGRAM CAN GO UP
OR DOWN DEPENDING UPON ECONOMIC
CIRCUMSTANCES.
ALSO REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
RETIRED TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE
SUPPORT THEM A REVISION PROPOSAL
OF PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO
CAL STARS IN ORDER TO REDUCE
SOME OF THE EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTION PRESSURE.
THANK YOU.
MONIQUE RENTALS ON BEHALF OF THE
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
COALITION WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INVESTMENT IN
EARLY EDUCATION AND FAMILY
CENTERED POLICIES WE LOOK
FORWARD TO LOOKING WE WORK FOR
TO LOOKING WITH WORKING WITH YOU
AND THE ADMINISTRATION.
ON THE WORK FORCE AND FACILITIES
PROPOSALS.
THE COALITION DOES CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE ONE BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT OVER THREE YEARS TO
SUPPORT OUR ROBUST MIX DELIVERY
SYSTEM AND WE REQUEST THAT YOU
ADOPT A SOMEONE NUMBER MCCARTY'S
PROPOSAL FOR RATE REFORM.
AS WELL AS THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ARMAR SURVEY THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DEBORAH BROWN WITH
CHILDREN NOW WE AT APPRECIATE
THAT GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT -- TO
LCF AND ALSO RECOGNIZING THOSE
ADDITIONAL COSTS THAT DISTRICTS
ARE FACING THAT ARE REALLY
IMPACTING THEIR ABILITY TO SERVE
SERVE KIDS TO PRIMARILY PENSIONS
AND ALSO PROVIDING SOME FUNDING.
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION AS WELL AS
A TEACHER RECRUITMENT AND
APPRECIATE THAT THE CONVERSATION
THE COMMITTEE HAD AROUND AM MORE
INVESTMENTS WE AGREE THAT WE
NEED TO BE DOING MORE PROVIDING
MORE RESOURCES FOR KIDS.
AND ADULTS AND FOR KIDS IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND THEN I WOULD ALSO
ECHO THE COMMENTS AROUND THE
EASY COALITION AND THE NEED --
TO AT THE AT THE FOCUS ON
CHILDREN AND AND THEIR FAMILIES
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
PARTS THAT FAMILIES NEED AND HOW
THAT THAT HELPS KIDS AS THEY
TRANSITION INTO INTO SCHOOL AGE
AND THEN.
ALSO SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL
BILLION DOLLARS FOR AN
ADDITIONAL SLOTS FOR INFANTS AND
TODDLERS AND RATE REFORM AS WELL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JEFF BARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS.
WITH REGARD TO SPECIAL EDUCATION --
YOU KIND OF MADE OUR JOB EASY
TODAY -- I THINK I WOULD AGREE
WITH THAT CONCERNS THAT WERE
EXPRESSED BY NEARLY ALL OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS MORNING.
A WE SUPPORT THE INCREASED LEVEL
OF FUNDING WE SUPPORT THAT
FUNDING BEING ON GOING.
WE CONTINUE TO OPPOSE THE A
CONCENTRATION GRANT APPROACHED
ALLOCATING THE FUNDS.
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA FOR
HIS LEGISLATION ON EQUALIZATION
AND THAT IS A CRITICAL FACTOR
THAT BELIEVE WE BELIEVE.
MUST BE INCLUDED IN ANY A
SOLUTION ON SPECIAL LIKE
EDUCATION ALSO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL FOR HIS
COMMENTS ABOUT EARLY
INTERVENTION AND INCLUSION --
WITH REGARD -- TO THE CAL STIRS
PROPOSAL WE SUPPORT THE
INCREASED CON -- ALLOCATION FOR
THE EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTION RATE.
ON THE CLASSIFIED SUMMER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM -- WE DID NOT
SUPPORT THE CREATION OF THAT
PROGRAM -- WE CONTINUE TO
BELIEVE THAT THOSE FUNDS WOULD
BE MORE EFFECTIVELY ALLOCATED TO
STUDENT PROGRAMS.
AND THEN LASTLY ON THE TEACHER
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT ROPOSALS --
WE VERY MUCH SUPPORT AND
APPRECIATE THOSE INVESTMENTS
THANK YOU.
HI DO NAY MCCARTY COLBERN
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION -- WE TO APPRECIATE
THE FOCUS OF THE GOVERNOR ON ON
OUR EARLIEST LEARNERS AND
FAMILIES WE DO HAVE.
A SKEWS ME WE DO HAVE A CONCERN
WITH THE REDUCTION IN THE COAL
ALSO -- THIS SHOULD BE A FLOOR
IT OUGHT NOT TO BE A CEILING AND
WE SHOULD RECOGNIZE THAT FOR ALL
PARTS OF THE SYSTEM -- WE ALSO
BILL WANT TO SHARE THAT AND WE
NEED MORE VOUCHERS JUST ACROSS
THE BOARD AND IT'S CHALLENGING
WHEN WE SEE.
A PRIORITY PUT IN SCHOOL AGE
YOUR INFANT TODDLER I THINK THAT
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT FOR
THE VOUCHER SIDE OF THE HOUSE.
OUR AGENCY SUPPORT FAMILIES AND
SO IF YOU PUT A A PRIORITY ON
ONE AGE BRACKET.
YOU'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO SKIP
OVER SOME OF THE MOST NEEDIEST
FAMILIES IN ORDER TO FILL YOUR
ALLOCATION FOR A SPECIFIC AGE.
SO -- IN REGARDS THE ASUS
PROGRAM ALSO IN TERMS OF A
CONVERSATION ABOUT SPACES MANY
OF THE AP'S ALSO HAVE THE ASUS
PROGRAM.
SO IF THEY WERE AT THE TABLE WE
COULD COME UP WITH SOME CREATIVE
IDEAS ON HOW WE CAN.
LOOK AT THE DIFFERENT FUNDING
POTS TO SUPPORT THE WHOLE FAMILY --
THE RATES HAVE TO BE ADDRESSED
IF WE DON'T IMPLEMENT THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN MARKET RATE SURVEY
AGAIN WE'RE GOING TO BE AT
TWENTY SIXTEEN LEVELS AND WE'VE
BEEN THERE BEFORE.
IT'S A BIGGER AMOUNT TO CATCH UP
SUPPORT THE WORK FORCE AND AGAIN
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE WORK YOU'RE DOING.
GOOD MORNING DONNA SNARES ARE ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILD CARE
RESOURCE CENTER IN THE CHILD
CARE ALLIANCE OF LOS ANGELES.
I'D LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY AND LAMONT FOR
THEIR COMMENTS.
ABOUT HITTING PARTS OF THE
SYSTEM AGAINST EACH OTHER I
THINK WE'VE ALL WORKED VERY HARD.
TO COME UP WITH A COMMON MESSAGE
AND WE APPRECIATE THE
RECOGNITION THAT THIS PUTS US IN
A DIFFICULT SITUATION -- THAT
SAID WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE AND
WERE PART OF THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
AT BUDGET COALITION WE SUPPORT
THE BILLION DOLLAR ASKED TO
EXPAND ACCESS FOR FAMILIES OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS.
AS OUTLINED IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAISES BILL AND ALSO URGE YOU.
TO INCLUDE THE RMR SURVEY UPDATE
IT'S A CRITICAL PART OF AB ONE
TWENTY FIVE TO BE ABLE TO BE
CURRENT WITH OUR MARKET RATE.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF AND WITH
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS ON HOW WE
MOVE FORWARD THE NEXT FEW WEEKS
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE MCANDREW
IT ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION
FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION -- TO BUILD UPON THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
ROCK OF FROM RIVERSIDE COUNTY --
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE
UNDERLYING POINT -- THAT NOT ALL
DISTRICTS AROUND THE STATE WILL
RECEIVE FUNDS UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL -- YOU'VE
PROBABLY SEEN THE DATA POINT
THAT ABOUT A QUARTER OF LEDS
RECEIVE THEM SO -- FOR YOU
MISTER MCCARTY'S FOR EXAMPLE SAN
JUAN WILL RECEIVE NOTHING
TORRANCE UNIFIED WILL RECEIVE
NOTHING SANTA BARBARA UNIFIED
WILL RECEIVE NOTHING RIVERSIDE
UNIFIED WILL RECEIVE NOTHING.
COLUSA COUNTY NO ALLEY I WOULD
RECEIVE ANY FUNDS UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WE KNOW THAT
THE THE NEED FOR A SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING IS STATEWIDE
THAT IS WHY WE ARE CO SPONSORING
AND THANK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT WE THINKTHAT IS THE RIGHT
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE EQUALIZATION
PRESCHOOL AND ALSO ADDRESS HIGH
COST NEEDS -- SO WE REALLY HOPE
THAT YOU'LL CONSIDER THAT FOR
THE SIX HUNDRED NINETY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS THAT IS BEING
PROVIDED -- BY THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ONE FINAL DATA POINT --
BUT WE'VE IT THROUGH OUR
CALCULATIONS IT'S ABOUT 6% OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS ABOUT
7% OF SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS
WOULD ACTUALLY GENERATE THESE
GRANTS SO THE OTHER 9392% WOULD
AGAIN GENERATE NO ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS AGAIN WHEN WE NEED NO.
THAT THE NEED TO STATEWIDE THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING SHARON MEMBERS
DEREK LENNIX ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
COUNSELORS BY NOW YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT THE COUNSELOR SHORTAGE
THAT IS OUT THERE PARTICULARLY
AFTER THE GREAT RECESSION.
PARTICULARLY IN LOW INCOME AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS -- FOR THAT
REASON THE ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS
THE TEACHER SERVICE CREDIT
SCHOLARSHIP BUT WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO SEE THE INCLUSION OF SCHOOL
COUNSELORS AS ELIGIBLE FOLKS WHO
COULD BE -- TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS FUNDS AND ACTUALLY BE IN
THE I UNDERSERVED AREAS ACROSS
THE STATE.
AND THEN SECONDLY ON BEHALF OF
THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR K.
TWELVE EDUCATION CLIENTS I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
NOT ONLY THREE BILLION FROM THE
JANUARY BUDGET BUT ALSO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION IN THIS MAY
REVISION. FOR PENSION
LIABILITIES WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S A CONVERSATION HAPPENING
ABOUT WHETHER THAT IS BEST PUT
IN THE CAL STAR SYSTEM AS THE
FIRST THREE BILLION IS -- OR THE
CALPERS SYSTEM WE'RE OPEN TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS THAT THE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY BE KEPT IN THE
FINAL BUDGET IN CONTINUE GO TO
GO TO SCHOOLS.
WE APPRECIATE YOU RECOGNIZING
THAT -- LIABILITY THAT SCHOOLS
ARE DEALING WITH RIGHT NOW THANK
YOU.
ERICA HAS BEEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION.
I JUST ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH A
LOT OF THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE ESPECIALLY DEREK'S
WITH REGARDS TO THE PERSON STIRS
ACCOUNTABILITY ISSUE OUR FUNDING
ISSUE -- I DO WANT TO SAY WITH
REGARD TO THE SPECIAL EDUCATION.
FUNDING THAT IS BEING PROVIDED
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT THEIR
ACTUAL THAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT
PROVIDING ONGOING FUNDING.
BUT AS ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS OF
AB FOR TWENTY EIGHT THE NEED FOR
EQUALIZATION THE NEED FOR
INCREASING FUNDING.
FOR ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
SPECIAL ED.
WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET JUST DOESN'T
QUITE GET THERE UNDERSTANDING
THE NEED TO WANT TO ADDRESS
EQUITY WANTING TO ADDRESS
POVERTY.
BUT TO COMPLETE THAT WAS SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING WHEN THE NEED
IS SO DESPERATE WITH IN
DISTRICTS THEMSELVES.
DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S THE RIGHT
SOLUTION AT THIS POINT IN TIME
EQUITY IS.
ADDRESSING THE HIGH COST NEEDS
IS.
I LIKE THE FACT THAT HE WANTS TO
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT A PRESCHOOL
FOR SPECIAL I THINK THAT'S A
REALLY GOOD THING THERE IS THAT
MANDATE.
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL SCHOOLS GET
VERY LITTLE IF NO FUNDING FOR
PRESCHOOL FOR SPECIAL AT SO WE
DO APPRECIATE THAT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS MICHAEL
HALL SAYS -- ON BEHALF OF THE
KERN COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS IN THE FORTY SEVEN
DISTRICTS AND CURRENT WE WANT TO
SPECIFICALLY THANK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MERCI CHIN
MISTER GALLAGHER FOR THEIR VERY
SPECIFIC COMMENTS ABOUT WHY
EQUITY NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
BEFORE WE BEGIN TO ADD OR EXPAND
NEW PROGRAMS AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN COLUSA
SUTTER RIVERSIDE SANTA BARBARA
VENTURA.
TORRANCE SENT TO A MENTAL OR ALL
FUNDED 2230% BELOW THE HIGHEST
FUNDED SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE
STATE FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION THAT
CATEGORICAL IS 40% OF ALL
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION.
UNTIL YOU ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
EQUITY IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
ADDING NEW PROGRAMS EXACERBATES
THE PROBLEM.
AND IT MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT
FOR THOSE UNDER FUNDED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN YOUR DISTRICTS. TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ANY NEW
PROGRAM THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
Q..
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER BAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION -- WE CAN
KERR AND GREEN APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION THAT THIS COMMITTEE --
HAS BEEN HAVING ABOUT THAT THE
LACK OF ADEQUATE FUNDING AND
OBVIOUSLY IF THE ISSUE WERE
ADDRESS IT WOULD MAKE A NUMBER
OF THESE OTHER CONVERSATIONS
MUCH MORE SIMPLE BUT WE SUPPORT
APPRECIATE THAT CONVERSATION --
WE DO SUPPORT -- THE COAL --
WE'RE DISAPPOINTED THAT IT HAS
GONE DOWN BUT WE DO SOME COURT
THE AMOUNT THAT WE'VE BEEN GIVEN
A WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT THE THAT
RAINY DAY RESERVE FOR EDUCATION
IS -- A FUNCTION OF A
CALCULATION WE DO THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE DIFFICULT TO HELP
PARENTS EDUCATORS -- AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS UNDERSTAND HOW
WE WE ARE HAVING A NUMBER OF
STRIKES AND SO MANY ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL --
HOW CAN WE TAKE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION AND PUT IT IN AN ACCOUNT
SO IT FURTHER MAKES THOSE
CONVERSATIONS MORE DIFFICULT WE
APPRECIATE AND UPPORT THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO HELP?
OUR DISTRICTS THAT WERE IMPACTED
BY THE WILDFIRES A PARTICULARLY
AND THOSE TYPE IS TO BUY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER WASN'T
ON GOING TO STAY BUT WE
APPRECIATE.
HIS INTRODUCTION OF AB TWO
NINETY SEVEN AND CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THAT AND HOPE THAT THOSE
EFFORTS TO PROTECT THOSE
DISTRICTS IMPACTED BY THE
WILDFIRES -- WELL HOT MANIFEST
THEMSELVES ADDITIONALLY WE WE DO
SUPPORT WITH THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING -- AS FAR AS PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL ONGOING FUNDS FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION WE ALSO VERY
MUCH SUPPORT AB FOR TWENTY EIGHT
IN REGARD TO SPECIAL IS A
EDUCATION EQUALIZATION FUNDING
TO US THE CONVERSATION IS YES WE
DESPERATELY NEED.
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS BUT OBVIOUSLY
THE CONVERSATION IS MUCH MORE
COMPLEX -- WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE HAVING A VERY
SYSTEMIC APPROACH TO DEALING
WITH THE MULTITUDE OF THE
INADEQUACIES IN REGARD TO
SPECIAL EDUCATION THE BETTER OFF
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS ARE GOING TO
BE.
WE SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE IS PROVIDED IN TRAILER
BILL IN REGARD TO CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND ADDITIONALLY SUPPORT
THE FUNNY THAT'S BEING PROVIDED
FOR RETAINING IS SUPPORTING WILL
PREPARE EDUCATORS -- FOR
COMPUTER SCIENCE AND THE FUNDS
THAT HAVE BEEN PROVIDED FOR
KINDERGARTEN EXPANSION -- WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING -- TO TO HELP THE AB FOR
EIGHTEEN FORTY ADJUSTMENTS THE
IMPACT INGLEWOOD THE IMPACT --
OAKLAND AND OTHERS AND WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES SUMMER SYSTEMS
PROGRAMS WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT --
AB FIFTY ONE ARE EXCUSE ME PROP
FIFTY ONE BOND FUNDS AND DO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE EXPEDITE
THOSE MOVING FORWARD WE ALSO
PARTICULARLY APPRECIATE AND
SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL --
OVERALL FUNDING THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING TO HELP TO
MAKE SURE THAT TEACHERS
RETIREMENT ARE WELL FUNDED ONTO
CAL STIRS WE UNDERSTAND THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF CONVERSATIONS TO
PROVIDE EQUITY ON THE CALPERS
SIDE.
WE DO SUPPORT -- WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED SEEN IN
ENCOURAGE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU?
GOOD MORNING KYLE HIGHLAND ON
BEHALF OF THE CAL STARS FUNDING
COALITION ASSOCIATION OF OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND COUNTY OFFICE EDUCATION.
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S THREE POINT ONE FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE UNFUNDED
LIABILITY -- CLEAR UNFUNDED
LIABILITY FOR THE CAL STAR SIDE
OUR APPRECIATIVE OF THE
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS PROVIDED IN THE REVISION --
ALSO ON BEHALF PARRIS UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD PROVIDE A
HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION THROUGH
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING IN A BUSY WITH
AVERAGE HOW CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING US FIFTEEN HUNDRED
ADMINISTRATORS ARE SUBSIDIZED
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE GREAT NEED --
ESPECIALLY THE LARGE NUMBER IN
THE KNOWLEDGE MEN OF THE LARGE
NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE UNDERSERVED
ON CHILDREN IN OUR STATE.
I'M A COUPLE OF ADDITIONAL
POINTS I'M REALLY WANT TO ECHO
THE ECU COALITIONS REQUEST AND
WE DO KNOW THAT THERE ARE GREAT
NEEDS IN OUR STATE ESPECIALLY
FOR INFANTS AND TODDLERS.
AND WANT TO ECHO OUR SUPPORT FOR
THE BILLION DOLLARS FOR BABIES
AND ARE ROBUST DELIVERY SYSTEM
WHICH IS REALLY CRUCIAL TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
I'M I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO ECHO --
MY APPRECIATION FOR THE COMMENTS
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMO AND
MCCARTY ABOUT ENSURING THAT WE
DO NOT HIT VERY VERY NEEDY
PROGRAMS AGAINST EACH OTHER IN
THIS VERY HARD TIME WE ALL KNOW
ALL OF THE PROGRAMS ARE
UNDERSERVED ARE UNDER FUNDED AND
WE NEED TO SUPPORT ALL OF THEM
SO REALLY.
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS ALSO
WOULD LIKE -- TO ECHO MY SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER PARTIES BILL
YOU'RE RIGHT REFORM BILL VERY
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AND REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO THE
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS AND WANT
TO PROVIDE SUPPORT AND DATA AS
YOU NEED IT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING BEVERLY YOU WANT TO
HAVE THE UW ASKED ME LOCAL THREE
NINE THIRTY WELL WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE MAY REVISE
AS IT BEGINS TO ADDRESS THE
SHORTAGE OF CHILD CARE FOR
WORKING FAMILIES AS PART THE
EASY COALITION.
WE WOULD LIKE TO EMPHASIZE
OUTSTANDING NEED FOR SLOTS FOR
INFANTS AND TODDLERS CURRENT
STAY FUNDING PROVIDES FUNDING IN
VOUCHERS FOR ONE IS SEVEN
ELIGIBLE BABIES TAUGHT FAMILIES
PAY FOR CARE.
AND THIS FUNDING STORES UNDER
PRE RECESSION LEVELS WE
RECOGNIZE IMPORTANCE OF AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS AS WELL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE MINISTRATION ON THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU.
HELLO ANGIE CARLENE WITH THE LOW
INCOME INVESTMENT FUND WE
FINANCE EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
FACILITIES AND HELP MAKE SURE
THEIR CO LOCATED WITH LOW INCOME
HOUSING AND HEALTH CLINICS -- ON
THE EARLY KERN EDUCATION
FACILITIES FUNDING -- WE WOULD
HAVE THAT THE GOVERNOR WOULD IT
WOULD IN HIS BUDGET LANGUAGE
WOULD ADOPT THE MULLIN BILL
LANGUAGE THAT IS ALSO CO
AUTHORED BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTHY AB FOUR
FIFTY TWO THIS WOULD -- ENABLE
TWO DIFFERENT PUT US TO NOT HAVE
TO DIFFERENT POTS OF MONEY WITH
TWO DIFFERENT TIME LINES INTO
DIFFERENT REGULATIONS AND RULES.
I'M AND I ALSO BEFORE I WORK FOR
THE LOAN CAN FOR INVESTMENT FUND
I WORKED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR
ALAMEDA COUNTY -- AND I CAN SAY
WITH OUR ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
VOUCHERS HALF OF THOSE CHILDREN
RECEIVING ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
VOUCHERS WERE ACTUALLY SCHOOL
AGE.
AND I THINK THAT'S ACTUALLY
PRETTY TRUE ACROSS THE STATE SO
IN TERMS OF NOT PITTING PROGRAMS
AGAINST EACH OTHER.
AFTER SCHOOL IS SCHOOL AGE CHILD
CARE AND SCHOOL AGE CHILD CARE
IS AFTER SCHOOL MY CHILDREN GO
TO AN AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM AND I
KNOW THAT THEIR FRIENDS ARE
CURRENTLY USING THEIR AFTER
SCHOOL.
THEIR SCHOOL AGE VOUCHERS THERE
AT VOUCHERS TO PAY FOR THEIR
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AND JAN DIETRICH
WITH THE PARTNERSHIP FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA AFTER SCHOOL
ADVOCACY ALLIANCE WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THE CONVERSATION
TODAY AROUND ASUS PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY -- IS THIS PROGRAM
SERVE THE SAME FAMILIES AS THE
CHILD CARE GROUPS AND THE
VOUCHER PROGRAMS -- AND WE OFTEN
SEE THESE KIDS ONCE THEY TURN
FIVE YEARS OLD AND OUR PROGRAMS
FOR SERVING THE SAME FAMILIES
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES.
UNLESS ACES PROGRAMS RECEIVE
CRITICAL FINDING THIS YEAR WE
ARE THAT BURNING HOUSE WE'RE
NEARLY ONE IN FOUR PROGRAMS WILL
CLOSE THEIR DOORS.
OUT BY TWENTY TWENTY WITHOUT IT
FINDING AND WHEN THOSE PROGRAMS
CLOSE THOSE IN NINETY ONE
THOUSAND FAMILIES AND CHILDREN
WILL JUST GO.
TO ADD ON TO THE LIST OF CHILD
CARE SO IF YOU'RE FIXING ONE
PLANT PROBLEM HERE THEY'RE JUST
GOING TO SHOW UP SOMEWHERE ELSE
WITHOUT FIXING ASUS PROGRAMS.
ON AND WANTED TO SPEAK TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS POINT
ABOUT LOCAL FINDING YES THESE
PROGRAMS DO YOU HAVE A LOCAL
MATCH.
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS INCREASE.
AT INVESTMENT OVER THE YEARS BUT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE BEING
HONEST WITH US THIS YEAR AND
SAYING THEY DON'T HAVE IT WITH
PROGRAMS.
WHEN DISTRICTS ARE ARE FUELED
WITH PENSION COSTS AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION THEY DON'T HAVE
FUNDING TO HELP SUBSIDIZE WHAT
THE STATE -- SHOULD BE PAYING
THAT FOR THE THEIR SHARE OF SO
PLEASE SUPPORT THE ONE HUNDRED
AND TWELVE POINT.
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
REQUEST FOR ASUS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING CATIONS A WITH A
CALIFORNIA CHILDCARE RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL NETWORK ONE OF THE
HARDEST PARTS THAT ARE IN OURS --
HAVING THEIR JOB IS BEING ABLE
TO FIND HELP FAMILIES FIND THE
CARE THAT THEY NEED AND CARE
THAT THEY CAN AFFORD WHETHER
IT'S THE TIME OF DAY THE TYPE OF
SETTING A WINE.
SO WE TO SUPPORT THE EASY
COALITIONS ONE BILLION DOLLAR
ASK FOR CHILD CARE SPACES -- AND
TO GO WITH THAT SO THAT THEY
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO FIND IT
PLEASE PUT PLACES WE KNOW OUR
SUPPLIES LIMITED IN CALIFORNIA
SO WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. FOR AND FACILITIES
GRANTS AND WHETHER IT'S THROUGH
THE PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED MULLIN
BILL OR ORIGINAL TBL LANGUAGE --
WE APPRECIATE IT FAMILY
CHILDCARE HOMES ARE INCLUDED BUT
HOPE THAT THE THE WAY THAT THEY
COULD UTILIZE THE GRANTS COULD
BE EXPANDED THAT TO BE MARKETING
TOWARDS THE TYPE OF SETTING AND
CARE THAT THEY PROVIDE.
AND FINALLY WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
RATE REFORM AND HOPE THAT IS
THAT'S WHAT'S MISSING IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS AND IS
INCLUDED AND ADOPTION OF THE
MOST RECENT ARE ARMAR SURVEY
THANKS.
MISS SHARE MEMBERS JOHN WHEN
YOU'RE ON THE OTHER CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOL ASSOCIATION JUST
WANTED TO SPEAK REALLY QUICK TO
THE MARY VISION.
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AROUND
COUNSELING AND ADMISSIONS
PRACTICES OF CHARTER SCHOOLS --
WE VIEW THIS PROPOSAL AS A AS
LARGELY BUILDING ON THE PROGRESS
WE MADE ON AB -- THIRTEEN SIXTY
WITH MR BONTA AND HAVE A HAVE A
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF OF
INCREASED TRANSPARENCY WE DO
THINK THERE ARE SOME.
INCIDENT INSTANCES WHERE THIS
SCRUTINY COULD BE -- PLACED ON
TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS AS WELL BUT
OVERALL WE WE DO NOT VIEW THIS
AS A IMPEDIMENT TO APPROPRIATE
EMISSIONS AND COUNSELLING
PRACTICES FOR OUR SCHOOLS THANKS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS J'AI
SURPRISE SAID WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION.
AS WE HAVE OUTLINED IN OUR
FEBRUARY LETTER TO THE GENERAL
PROPOSAL AND WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
THE SAME PRIORITIES.
FIRST AND FOREMOST WE'RE HOPING
TO BE ABLE TO FIND SOME FUNDS
FOR D. OPPOSED BY DOWN FORTY
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES IN
THE SCHOOL POOL.
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S --
FORESIGHT TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE
FUNDING -- TO ADDRESS THOSE
KINDS OF PENSION ISSUES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL BUT IF YOU DON'T
PROVIDE SOME FUNDING FOR THE
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES IN
THE SCHOOL POOL DO WOULD CREATE
A DISINCENTIVE TO HARD TO NEXT
CLASSIFIED BECAUSE I'LL RISING
COSTS.
ARE GOING UP JUST AS MUCH AS A
THIS THOSE SIDE SO WE WOULD URGE
YOU TO FIND -- THE WAYS AND
MEANS TO PROVIDE THE FUNDING AND
THAT THAT'S OUR NUMBER.
ONE PRIORITY AND THEIR NUMBER
ONE ASK.
GET IT TO ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
OUTLINED BEFORE.
AS ALWAYS OUR MEMBERS DEAL WITH
ALL THE ISSUES AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL TO MAKE SURE THE KIDS GET
TO SCHOOL ON TIME GET FED.
ADDRESS ALL THE ENEMIES OR I'LL
BREAK ALL THOSE THINGS AND SO WE
GET BACK TO THE IDEA OF GETTING
ENOUGH.
TRAINING FUNDS WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR PROVIDING FORTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FOR TEACHERS AND
PARA PROFESSIONAL BUT THAT'S
JUST ONE CLASSIFICATION.
OF OUR MEMBERSHIP -- LAST YEAR --
DEPRIVE ADMINISTRATION WAS ABLE
TO PROVIDE FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
AND THAT FUNDING WENT TO SCHOOL
SAFETY TO ENSURE THAT ALL.
ALL STAFF ARE ABLE TO DEAL WITH
THE CRISIS AT OUR OCCUR NOW
SCHOOLS AND FINALLY WE THINK
IT'S HIGH DO TIME -- TO ADDRESS
THE INEQUITIES AND THE SHORTFALL
IN FUNDING FOR A SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION -- WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN HAVING TO WALK FURTHER
INFO THERE ARE YOU REALLY HAVE
TO FIND SOME WAYS TO PROVIDE
SOME OF THE SOME COLA.
AND SOME EQUALIZATION FUNDING
THAT WE PROPOSE A MODICUM A MILE
TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE BUT FIRST
AND FOREMOST IS THE POZA OFFSET
THAT WE'RE HOPING TO GET A A
POSITIVE REFORM DEMONSTRATIONS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING PATTY PER NUMBER
FROM THE CHILD CARE LAWCENTER I
WILL JUST ECHO AND SUPPORT THE
STATEMENTS ON THE ECT COALITION
PRIORITIES -- MORE SPACES IN A
VARIETY OF SETTINGS TO MEET THE
CHILD CARE CRISIS THAT WE HAVE A
SPECIALLY SLOTS FOR INFANTS AND
TODDLERS -- WE SUPPORT YOUR RATE
REFORM INITIATIVE -- MISTER
CHAIR AND HOPE THAT IT WILL
INCLUDE THE UPDATED OUR AMMAR.
AND ON FACILITIES WE'RE GRATEFUL
THAT -- THE BILL -- IT BEFORE
FIFTY TWO AS WELL AS THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE INCLUDES LANGUAGE
FOR FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
WHO -- WE'VE LOST ONE THIRD OF
THOSE PROVIDERS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT AND WE NEED
TO SUPPORT THEM SO THAT CHILDREN
CAN GET CARE IN A VARIETY OF
SETTINGS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS SAM
NOT SURE THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION -- LAWSON'S
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
SEEKING FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT A
COMPREHENSIVE SCHOOL NUTRITION
AND ONE IS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PILOT PROGRAM.
THAT PROVIDES QUALIFY
NUTRITIONAL PROFESSIONALS WILL
PROVIDE DIRECT SUPPORT.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TRAININGS
PAGINATION.
AN EVIDENCE BASED RESOURCES THE
VARIOUS ELIE IS IN SCHOOLS.
WE SUPPORT A TWO MILLION DOLLARS --
FOR CARS THAT RECOGNIZING THE
THE FEDERAL GRANT HAS ENDED.
WHICH PERSON A REAL BILL RUBIO'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN
IMPLEMENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ENGLISH LEARN A ROAD MAP
INITIATIVE -- WE ARE IN SUPPORT
A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO CASTERS
THIS GIVES ALL AND FOR A
700-730-00460 SEVEN DOLLARS IN
SAVINGS TO LAKE OVER THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY FISCAL YEAR.
AND FINALLY LAKE -- CONTINUES TO
SUPPORT THREE MILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST FOR THE LOS BEFORE
MISTER IS FOR THREE YEARS THE
ALLOWS THREE STUDENTS WHO ARE
FALLING BEHIND.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
AARON EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE
CELL BUT ADMINISTRATORS OF
CALIFORNIA.
I'D FIRST LIKE TO SAY WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT TO A SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND APPRECIATE ALL
DOLLARS THAT ARE COMING TO
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES TO
SERVE CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES.
I WOULD SAY HOWEVER WE SHARE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS YOU'VE
HEARD TODAY ABOUT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THESE FUNDS --
AND WOULD IN FACT SUPPORT.
A PROPOSAL TO EQUALIZE FUNDING
SUCH AS UNDER AB.
FOR TWENTY EIGHT I'M SO WE
APPRECIATE THAT PROPOSAL WE HAVE
ALSO PREPARED A LETTER THAT
WE'VE SENT TO YOUR OFFICES --
WITH ADDITIONAL RECOMMENDATIONS
AS WELL AS THE ONE I MENTIONED
AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH YOU THANK YOU.
CAN LOW'S REPRESENTING THE
CORPORATION FOR EDUCATION
NETWORK INITIATIVES IN
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTIVE OF THE
FIFTEEN MILLION ADDITIONAL FUNDS
FOR IMPROVING BROADBAND
CONNECTIVITY FOR OUR SCHOOLS AND
STAND READY TO SERVE -- THE
ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT AS
THEY SEE FIT.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERG WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION I WANNA LIVE MY COMMENTS
WITH THAT YOU SEE COALITION AS
WELL AS OUR PARTNERS BEAUTY W. I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
MORE FUNDING GO TOWARDS RECENT
SLOTS BUT WE'RE REALLY ENCOURAGE
FOR THE CONVERSATION HAPPENING
AROUND CHILD CARE -- FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE I ONE OF MY MY
COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUES AT
CSEA WE'D LIKE TO SEE PARITY IN
THE PERSON STAR SIDE OF THINGS
THE CLASSIFIEDS ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR THEIR WORK IN A COSTS I'M
PLAY.
MAINLY ON OUR LOWEST WAGE
WORKERS WE ALSO ARE REALLY
ENCOURAGED BY THE INCLUSION OF
THE SUMMER BRIDGE FUND OR
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE ASSISTANCE
AS A COUPLE DIFFERENT NAMES BUT
ULTIMATELY WHAT IT DOES IS IT
ALLOWS OUR LOWEST WAGE WORKERS
TO MAKE IT THROUGH THE SUMMER
MONTHS WE HAD A REALLY.
STRONG TAKE UP IN THE FIRST YEAR
SO WE HOPE THAT WE CAN TO THE
FUNDING CONTINUE IN THE BUDGET
FOR ANOTHER YEAR THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS
SLURPEE BE ON BEHALF OF LA'S
BEST AFTER SCHOOL ENRICHMENT
PROGRAM WE SERVE TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND KIDS IN TWO HUNDRED
SCHOOLS IN THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS LOS ANGELES.
90% OF OUR STUDENTS QUALIFY FOR
FREE OR REDUCED PRICE MEALS 45%
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS.
AND OUR PROGRAM HAS PROVEN
OUTCOMES WE HAVE UCLA STUDIES
THAT SHOW IT HELPS WITH.
ATTENDANCE IT HELPS GRADUATION
RATES AND REDUCE JUVENILE CRIME --
IS ALSO CRITICAL FOR WORKING
FAMILIES WHO CAN'T TAKE THEIR
KIDS UP AT THREE PM.
WE RELY ON ASUS FUNDING TO DO
ALL OF THIS WE ALSO DO ROBUST
PRIVATE FUNDRAISING -- IN WEEKS
YEAR LOCAL MATCH EVERY YEAR AND
YET THIS YEAR WERE STILL RUNNING
A MILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT NEXT
YEAR THAT'S GOING TO GO UP TO
OVER TWO MILLION WITHOUT A
SOLUTION -- OUR DISTRICT DOESN'T
HAVE ADDITIONAL MONEY TO HELP
WITH THIS THAT'S WHY THEY'RE
ALSO SUPPORTING OUR BUDGET
REQUEST FOR HUNDRED TWELVE POINT
EIGHT MILLION.
WERE REALLY LEAN ORGANIZATION WE
CUT COSTS WHEREVER WE CAN BUT
MINIMUM MINIMUM WAGE HAS JUST
MADE OUR FINANCIAL SITUATION
COMPLETELY UNSUSTAINABLE --
WE'RE CURRENTLY CUTTING SERVICES
TO STUDENTS AND WERE AT RISK OF
CLOSING LEAVING OUR STUDENTS
WITH NOWHERE TO GO AFTER THE
BELL RINGS.
WHEN I JUST ECHO MY THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUE JENNIFER THE
CALIFORNIA AFTER SCHOOL ADVOCACY
ALLIANCE -- WE NEED A SOLUTION
FOR ASUS PROGRAMS AND WE NEED IT
NOW WE APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION
TO IT WE APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY
IS LEADERSHIP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TO VISITORS TRIAL
THREE SIXTY LOS ANGELES WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT IN THIS HOUSE IS
COMMITMENT IN THIS COMMITTEES
COMMITMENT TO EARLY EDUCATION --
WE SUPPORT THE EASY COALITIONS
ASKED WE SUPPORT WOMEN'S CAUCUS
ASK.
AND WE WERE ONE REMIND YOU THAT
THE FOR STILL BEFORE CHEERS OF
FOR A STE LEGS TO THE CHAIR OF
EARLY EDUCATION.
THE FIRST ONE IS ACCESS OR SLOTS
AND WE SUPPORT THE BILLION
DOLLAR FOR BABY ASK.
AND AND ALL OTHER COMMITMENTS TO
REALLY -- PRESCHOOL -- WE
SUPPORT -- THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATE REFORM.
THAT'S THE SECOND LEG.
THE THIRD LEG IS FACILITIES WE
CAN'T DO THIS WITHOUT FACILITIES
IN THE SUIT SO THAT FOR ELEAZAR
THE THAT THE PROBLEM.
AND FINALLY THE WORK FORCE IT
REALLY GOOD AS THE PEOPLE WHO DO
THIS.
AND SO WE'RE QUESTION IS A LOT
OF ATTENTION WE APPRECIATE THE
TWO HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILLION
FOR THAT COMMITMENT.
AND WE WOULD REMIND YOU THAT IS
PRETTY IMPORTANT.
THE AD.
ADVISORS NAVIGATORS AND
COUNSELORS TO THIS WORKFORCE.
EVERY STUDY THAT SHOWS THAT THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING THAT THE
STUDENTS AND THE CAREER PEOPLE
ASK FOR IS HOW TO DEVISE THE
SYSTEM TO GET THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHRIS FOR AMERICA
HISTORIC CALIFORNIA.
WHEN I THINK THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
LEADERSHIP IN SUPPORTING THE IT
YOU KNOW EXPANDING EARLY
CHILDHOOD CARE?
AND WE WANT TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF THE EARLY
EDUCATION COALITION -- ONE ECHO
THE COMMENTS EARLIER REGARDING --
ALIGNING THE LANGUAGE BETWEEN
THE TRAILER BILL.
FOR EARLY LEARNING AND CARE
FACILITIES AND INFRASTRUCTURE
WITH A. B. -- FOUR FIVE TWO THE
CURRENT LANGUAGE IN THE TRAILER
BILL EXCLUDES ELEAZAR AND YET
35% OF HEAD START AGENCIES ARE
LOCATED INSIDE ELLIE ETS BUT
WERE EVER HEAD START AGENCIES
ARE LOCATED OR PROGRAMS ARE
LOCATED.
THEY ARE STILL SERVING -- THE
POOREST FAMILIES WHO QUALIFY
UNDER FEDERAL POVERTY GUIDELINES
SO WE PROPOSE USING THE LANGUAGE
THAT'S NOW CONTAINED IN A BEFORE
FIVE TO SECTION THREE OF THE
BILL -- EDUCATION CODE ADDING
EDUCATION CODE EIGHTY TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT THAT FOR TO DEFINE
WHAT CONSTITUTES.
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE PROGRAMS TO
QUALIFY FOR THE FACILITIES
GRANTS THANKS.
GOOD MORNING MARK THOMAS ON
BEHALF BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS ARE ACCESS.
I WERE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
CONTINUED INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND AS THE CHAIRMAN
MENTIONED WE NEED TO GO OUT TO
GET MORE REVENUES AND THAT MAY
REQUIRE GOING TO THE VOTERS IN
THE FUTURE BALLOT INITIATIVE.
BUT FOR THE TIME BEING IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET ON
THERE'S A LOT TO CELEBRATE WE
APPRECIATE THAT ONGOING COLA FOR
LC FF EVEN THOUGH IT'S BEEN A
REDUCTION FROM THE PRIOR COLA.
ESTIMATES WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
AUGMENTATION OF A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CHARACTERS -- RELIEF FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT WE NEED MORE REVENUES TO
SUPPORT ON THE CALPERS SIDE.
WE ARE VERY PLEASED TO SEE THE
PROPOSALS IN THE MAY REVISION
REGARDING THAT TEACHER
ADMINISTRATOR AND PARA
PROFESSIONAL.
OUT WORKFORCE INVESTMENTS ARE
SPECIFICALLY FOR LOAN
FORGIVENESS FOR NEW RECRUITMENT
OF TEACHERS ARE TRAININGS FOR
PARA PROFESSIONALS AND TEACHERS
AND ALSO THE FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
AND SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
CAPACITY BUILDING WE KNOW WE
HAVE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT WITH
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS FOR THIS --
PROFESSIONALS AND EDUCATORS HOW
WE CAN HELP TO IT -- TO IMPROVE
STUDENT OUTCOMES AND WE HAVE A
CONCERNS ON TO ADD TO PROPOSAL
THAT I MENTIONED FOR THE TIME
BEING ONE OF THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD
ON THE COMMENTS -- FROM THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE DíAS AS
WELL AS THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
INEQUITIES OF THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD CREATE -- WE WOULD
PREFERRED THEY QUALITY STATION
THROUGH THE A BEFORE TWENTY
EIGHT ARE LEGISLATION.
AND THE OTHER CONCERN WE HAVE
HAS TO DO WITH PROP FIFTY FOUR
IN THE USE OF THOSE REVENUES I
IT'S BEEN MENTIONED BY THE CHAIR
AND OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
BUT THOSE FUNDS COULD BE BETTER
USE OF FOR SUPPORTING KIDS -- IN
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOLS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BOB WAGNER FOR FRESNO
UNIFIED SPEAKING SPECIAL
EDUCATION AS OF SO MANY OTHERS --
A WITH ARE VERY PLEASED ABOUT
THE BUDGETARY COMMITMENT WHICH
IS SO CRITICAL AND THE
GOVERNOR'S TAKING THE LEAD ON WE
FEAR HOWEVER THAT THE
DISTRIBUTION METHODOLOGY IS A
GREAT LEAP BACKWARD AS FAR AS
THE LC OFFICE COMMITMENTS. TO
EQUITY RATIONALITY AND
TRANSPARENCY JUST IN OUR
CIRCUMSTANCES YOU MAY KNOW WE'RE
THE FOURTH LARGEST DISTRICT IN
THE STATE IN THE ENTIRE NATION
WE HAVE THE SECOND HIGHEST
CONCENTRATION OF INTENSE POVERTY.
OUR SPECIAL EDUCATION GENERAL
FUND.
CONTRIBUTION THE SEVENTY THREE
MILLION LAST YEAR AND
SKYROCKETING.
OF OUR YIELD FROM THE SIX
HUNDRED NINETY SIX MILLION
PROPOSAL IS ZERO DOLLARS AND
ZERO CENTS THANK YOU.
I LATEST A BLADDER WHAT DISTRICT
AGAIN ARE YOU REPRESENT FRESNO
UNIFIED FRESNO OKAY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ERIC PETERSON FROM
BANANAS A TOOK A RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL IN ALAMEDA COUNTY.
JUST WONDERED G. DO SUPPORT THE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR BABIES OR
LOWEST INCOME PARENTS CAN HAVE
ACCESS.
AND SECONDLY CONTINUE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE RATE FOR FORMER
GROUP FOR ALTERNATE PAYMENT AND
TELL FIVE CENTERS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SURE MEMBERS THERE
ARE SIMPLY HAVE TO THE CAMPAIGN
FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY ALONG
NOT ON TODAY'S AGENDA JUST
WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO ESTABLISH AN
INTERSECTION TOLL DATA SYSTEM --
AND WE HOPE THAT IS
CONVERSATIONS CONTINUED IN THE
COMING WEEKS.
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO PRIORITIZE
THIS A CRITICAL STATE TOLD IT'S
REALLY IMPERATIVE TOUGH HELPING
CLOSE. TO UNDERSTANDING STUDENT
OUTCOMES AND HELPING CLOSE
EQUITY CAPS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TO THE CHALLENGE OF
IT WITH THE GAS PROJECT
CALIFORNIA HERE TO LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM
THE EASY COALITION -- I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE -- WE SO APPRECIATE
ALL THE CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE
HAPPENING AROUND EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION -- UPS HAPPIER AND
DOWNSTAIRS WE JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE OUT WHATEVER FUNDS WE PUT
OUT THERE ARE APPROPRIATE.
OF WHAT WE SEE IS A HUGE NEED IN
IN PRINT COLOR SPACES AND HOW
CAN WE HAVE A SURPLUS IN THE
BUDGET -- A THRIVING ECONOMY AND
NOT HAVE ANY SPACES IN THE
BUDGET SO WE HOPE -- WE ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE ALONG WITH THE
FACILITIES ISSUE WE APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR ADDRESSING A INFANT
AND TODDLER -- FACILITIES AND
HIS BUDGET WE THINK THERE SHOULD
NEEDS TO BE DONE MORE -- ADDRESS
A PROJECT RECENTLY RELEASED A
REPORT OUT DATA ADDRESSES THE
FACILITIES CHALLENGE ACROSS THE
STREET SO ACROSS THE STATE TO
REPORT TO WORKING WITH YOU --
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THAT IN
THE BUDGET THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JACKIE ALONG WITH
OF THE GRAYSON STAND AND TOP
PART IN CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN I
WENT ONLINE MY COMMENTS TO THE
EAST HE COALITION --
SPECIFICALLY I'M ALSO GONNA
HIGHLIGHTS SUPPORT -- FOR RATE
REFORM THANK YOU OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AND WITH THAT
WE WILL ADJOURN